over the last year i've documented my
experience reading for the very first
time the incredible story of berserk the
magnum opus of one late great kentaro
miura who tragically passed away in 2021
to kick off this massive video for those
of you that want to read it but would
also like to know my spoiler-free
thoughts on it first my woodline review
of my experience with this story is as
follows
this is quite literally a story that has
changed my outlook on life for the
better and before i spend what will no
doubt be an ungodly amount of time
sharing with you my discovery of that
fact i'd first like to do something a
little different for those of you that
do not wish to read this story or are on
the fence and so for the next couple of
minutes i will try to convince you why
this is a life-changing story worthy of
your time why you should read berserk
shonen is the most popular genre of
manga in japan and as a result has
spawned some of the most popular
releases and indeed anime to hit the
rest of the world many of which i've
praised and covered on this very channel
stories that tell a triumphant journey
focusing on perseverance friendship and
a general coming of age messages and
themes that are important for a younger
audience to learn stories that hollywood
and the west love to make films about
where our young hero in mind or in body
grows from an experience and becomes an
adult then the credits roll we leave the
theater change the channel or we put
down that comic thinking what a terrific
story but this is not the story berserk
tells there's more to life than just the
first 20 years of it and due to that
fact berserk asks questions like what
happens when you have trauma can you
ever truly heal what happens when your
happily ever after never comes what
happens if you find yourself having
grown up and you can't remember or
understand why you feel like there's
something wrong a moment we can't
remember but when we know is there
because even in our earliest memories
we've walked through life with a limp
berserk is a story that helped me
realize what's important it helped me
realize that i was being selfish and it
helped me become i think a better person
in the same way dragon ball helped me to
learn life lessons as a child berserk
helped to illuminate what it is an adult
should learn on their journey through
life through showing us the horrors of
human nature as well as its beauty
kintara miura alongside the main
character guts shows us where trauma can
hide and manifest and where love and
life can thrive despite adversity this
is a tale that pushes the boundary sets
a new standard and deals with some of
the most compelling character writing
i've seen committed to the pages of any
manga and so
if there's any story i recommend reading
from beginning to where it ultimately
leaves off
it's berserk i will say however
something to keep in mind is that this
is not a shonen it's a seinen manga it's
meant for adults and if you're someone
that struggles with excessive violence
assault and females and males alike as
well as depictions of horrifically
contorted monsters far beyond what your
wildest dreams can conjure now's your
chance to click out with that out of the
way it's time to finally share with you
all
my journey through berserk
the rest of this video will be divided
into five segments with each segment
representing my coverage of one of the
five main arcs of berserk and these five
arcs are the black swordsman ark the
golden age arc the conviction arc the
falcon of the millennium empire arc and
finally the fantasia arc where kantara
miora last contributed to this
incredible story within each arc segment
i will be sharing my experience with
that arc my immediate impressions my
review of different choices and of
course my deconstruction of the story
and predictions for the future in
hindsight i got some things kind of
right and most of it totally wrong so
enjoy that oh also for those of you that
have seen some of these review portions
already i should let you know that my
editors have added some extra surprises
in there to enhance the experience from
new edits to full-blown animations to
help bring this story to life throughout
this journey you'll notice the exact
moment miura figured out what the story
was going to be and of course the
mind-bendingly brilliant artistic
evolution of this very series this is 10
months worth of work and i hope you all
enjoy
my entire journey through
berserk
[Music]
so with that said it's time for me to
dive into the first page of berserk
okay in storytelling i find few aspects
to be more irritating or offensive than
when a story is
boring
but let me tell you berserk is not
boring and while i've never been an
individual to be won over by big man
swings big sword good oh god still be
swinging that sword pretty good like i
said in the beginning i had literally
zero expectations going into this but
damn this story from the opening pages
right all the way through is balls to
the wall gore violence and tragedy now
it's clear that this arc is an
establishing one in many respects it
flashes from setting to setting
encounter to encounter until it doesn't
but that's okay because this arc's main
objective is to teach us about one
character above all others
guts
but that's not to say that this arc
doesn't have some stunning visuals
brilliant narrative choices and some of
the best paneling i've seen from a
series in years but be warned it gets
pretty intense from here on in i mean
the opening pages alone are crazy so
like i'm sitting there holding this
leather-bound behemoth of a volume with
two hands by the way because it's a
thick and heavy boy i opened the first
page and bam this is what i see now i
know we're taught in english class to
grab our reader's attention in the
opening paragraph or as soon as we can
but jeez i don't think that this is what
mr troy was talking about when he said
that and it's not at all how i thought
i'd be spending my saturday but
the opening chapters primarily concern
themselves with establishing the world
the main character's guts and a smaller
supporting character called puck who
will no doubt play a massive role in the
dynamic moving forward which i am very
grateful for seeing as the closest thing
guts could muster to light-hearted
banter would be him clutching someone's
light heart in his fist now full
disclosure that actually hasn't happened
yet in my read-through but i would be
surprised if it doesn't ever happen
given what this introductory portion has
shown me thus far in saying that the
first few chapters did a fantastic job
in sucking me into the story which given
that this material was written in the
80s gave me tremendous hope for the
future of this series normally with more
middle-of-the-road serializations from
this era the age of the product is felt
however a number of properties managed
to achieve that timeless feel with their
focus and dedication to character and
world building thankfully berserk does
just that berserk feels like it could
have been written this year in many ways
helped in part by its dedication to the
medieval dark fantasy aesthetic coloring
the encounters and choices made by
characters from the weaponry the armor
or even the transportation used need to
get to the next town faster well you
gotta hit your ride with some randomer
on the back of a horse and cart all
hateful eight style but the crowning
jewel of the story for me has to be how
it imbues different individuals with
their respective characteristics in
other words i love this story's
characterization guts is a character
that from the moment i saw him filled me
with dread i had the worst feeling in
the back of my mind that he would just
be another mindless personality-less
muscle-bound meat head for us the
audience to self-insert into but he's
not in fact i thought the anglo-mura
approached the character with felt both
appropriate for the time and
retroactively worked for my
sensibilities today he very much feels
like the stoic action hero appropriate
for the time period but there's a little
more under the surface to keep me
interested a tragic backstory were drip
fed over the course of the narrative
that i'm sure we'll see more of as time
passes by but what helped me latch onto
him the most was how his actions do not
match what he says just listening to him
you'd swear he's the most heartless man
alive but in reality he's probably
harvested more hearts from the corpse of
his victims okay i'm kidding jokes aside
what he says versus how he acts colored
my impression of him early which i think
is great from the moment we meet him as
he wanders into a seemingly random town
to the hostility he's met with and
ultimately the violence he strikes down
unto them it's almost like he's trying
to convince himself that he is a certain
way focused on his mission to achieve
his goal which we still don't know yet
at this point at numerous times in this
story early on he vocally disparages and
denigrates those in society that are
weak as both pathetic and not worth life
let alone his consideration like puck an
elf type creature he stumbles across by
chance and because of who he is gut
shows no sympathy or care despite his
circumstances and yet whenever he seems
to encounter someone in need including
puck he gets involved more often than he
would let you think and if that were it
i wouldn't have thought to address it
there are lots of characters like that
in anime vegeta very much is that
character right now in dragon ball super
to a much more light-hearted degree
might i add someone that doesn't want to
show how much he cares and hides it
behind a thin facade but ultimately when
the chips are down he does help every
time but that's not who guts is every
time guts might do something
accidentally or overtly righteous he
shows visible frustration with himself
as if he's scolding or trying to
suppress who he truly is instead of
accepting it and at this point we're not
really sure why he does this this makes
him not only an interesting anti-hero of
sorts but also a character that is
defined by his actions and by what he
says with each means of exposition
showing and telling working in
opposition to one another forming a
narrative puzzle of sorts that pulls
double duty creating a sense of depth
and conflict within the character
naturally while also hinting towards a
scarring history or backstory for guts
as the protagonist leaving us as an
audience wonder why the charade why the
conflict of action and mindset and for
us to ask that sort of question this
early on to achieve that level of
character in the first few chapters it's
nothing short of remarkable and that's
not even to make mention of these
strange existential orwellian dreams
he's haunted by hinting perhaps out of
fear he has of what tasks lay before him
on his journey only time will tell i
guess oh also this brand or scar on his
neck summons evil spirits so not ideal
could it be connected to the nightmares
well i mean i've read all of the arcs so
yeah it sure seems to be the case and
either way it makes for some really cool
looking imagery and while i'm on the
topic of imagery man this manga looks
good like
that's s
i say made the ball i'm very impressed
not just with the anatomy layouts or use
of shadows but the restraint he employs
to draw attention to certain aspects and
to not clutter his pages also for
instance right after pucks will they
won't they budding bromance with god
starts the two of them hit a ride
through the dark monster-ridden forest
with an old man and a young girl this
for me was where the manga really caught
my attention in the best of ways it's
important in this moment for us to see
the dead rising from the depths of the
forest as if spewing out from the fog
and miura's use of white space helps to
achieve that nicely also i'm a big fan
of spooky scary skeletons so extra
points for that and once again he'd be
swinging that big sword pretty big
clearly this was drawn by a mangaka that
loved what he was doing the attention to
detail the generous page space dedicated
to the initial strike with ample time
given to the follow through on the
following pages every single time he
swings this fridge door at someone it's
given special treatment as it should
it's an awesome shot it looks so good in
fact i didn't even really mind the fact
that the only reason they came into
conflict with the skeletons in the first
place came down to the idiotic choice of
a little girl oh she's a demon and she
trapped them on purpose
hey that's pretty good
i'm not even remotely kidding when i say
that around every corner something
happens that quickly grabs your
attention in this manga and it never
lingers long enough either to get boring
or overstay its welcome in fact it felt
like miura was trying his best to
express what these scenes needed in as
efficient a way as possible take for
example this scene with the little girl
first we see that gutz is busy with the
spooky
second we see puck notice something in
the carriage third we see the
disembodied head of the driver fourth we
see guts and puck react with gutz's
reaction reinforcing his good tough guy
persona hesitating not wanting to hurt
the little girl and in the process gets
stabbed this is all slowly but
effectively building tension to the
final shot where he swings his big sword
yet again only this time unlike all of
the other instances that preceded this
big swing there's no focus on the gore
of the situation there's no focus on how
badass the moment might be it's looked
on from afar as the dramatic and tragic
unfortunate death that it is one that
befell a young innocent girl this
this is the difference between a mangaka
that just wants to draw cool stuff and a
mangaka that wants to draw a great manga
that he believes in furthermore
kintaramira really leans into the
anguish frustration and hurt in both
guts and puck during the aftermath as
they have to contend with this growing
swarm of the undead and again the focus
isn't on the awesome visuals that do
eventually come but instead it's
focusing on the struggle and mental
state of guts as he coughs up blood and
staggers to his feet before he
eventually psychs himself up pushes his
humanity to the side and bodies the
seemingly bottomless swarm of the undead
in what i can only describe as an
impossibly exhausting effort with it
being once again presented expertly in
this impressive two-page spread and i
say impressive for a specific reason
what's interesting about this shot to me
at least is how miura decided to present
the character of guts ask any artist
where expression comes from and nine
times out of ten they will often say
either the eyes the mouth or some place
on the face itself most action shots in
manga place heavy emphasis on this for
that reason but as you can see miura
drew him without a face in this shot
instead opting to shroud it in shadow
now on top of it looking cool it plays a
further role in visually communicating
his characterization made all the more
effective when you realize that the
previous massive swings of a sword that
we've seen came with this shadow effect
over his face also reinforcing the
notion that wild guts can bring himself
to perform these grotesque acts and
ignore the consequences of the life he
leads for him to actually live with it
he has to push a significant part of
himself away removing his humanity both
figuratively through what he says and
demonstrated visually through the shadow
over his face in these illustrations in
other words he's forcing himself to
become a monster to defeat these
monsters a perfect marriage of the
visual and narrative utility and as dawn
breaks through the darkness of the night
bringing an end to the battle an
ethereal otherworldly voice bellows from
deep in the woods citing and i quote we
are always watching and you belong to me
we want your heart in the past gus has
criticized the weak time and again
because he believes that the weak can't
be free and now having heard this voice
i'm starting to see why guts places so
much emphasis on freedom now yeah but
first a quick word from our sponsor
i've mentioned before that this year is
one for health and fitness in fact as
you watch this i'll be in scotland
climbing ben nevis the first of many
challenges i hope to overcome in the
coming months to achieve this i need to
ensure that i'm meeting healthily which
sure isn't easy on a schedule as busy as
mine these days thankfully that's where
today's sponsor has been a great help
hello fresh is a delicious recipe box
service that offers fit and wholesome
options that allow you to eat well
without sacrificing flavor all of
hellofresh's recipes come with
pre-portioned ingredients
which is not only a huge time saver when
it comes to prep and clean up but thanks
to their easy to follow instructions it
allows me to prepare fresh meals without
much extra thought what i've personally
appreciated is the versatility of the
service there are a wealth of tasty
options to explore from all over the
world and on top of that you can
customize them with the option of adding
swapping or upgrading protein each week
or even throwing in protein into your
veggie dishes for extra flexibility
there are delicious extras like desserts
and sides and even premium meals for
those special occasions seriously head
over to hellofresh.com right now and see
the wealth of recipes on offer if you
use code not mark 16 you can also get up
to 16 free meals and three surprise
gifts i seriously recommend it and
what's great is that it's incredibly
sustainable too not only are you wasting
25 percent less food on a hole but hello
fresh is in fact 72 percent cheaper than
dining at a restaurant and happens to be
the first carbon neutral meal kit where
nearly all of the packaging is
recyclable delicious recipes effortless
prep easy goal tracking and it's
sustainable that's hard to beat if that
sounds good to you then once again go to
hellofresh.com and use code not mark 16
for up to 16 free meals and three
surprise gifts the next section is by
far and away the most substantial story
sequence we've received thus far and i
think if you were to ask anyone who's
read this material what the best part of
the arc was it'd be this mini arc
concerning guts's dance with the evil
count of this poor misfortunate village
it's got all the normal bells and
whistles i've come to expect from this
story thus far only everything is turned
up to 11 with more gore than i've seen
in the manga with a touch of body horror
and by a touch of body horror i mean
holy hell what the hell is that thing
kill it with fire
up until now the story rightfully has
focused on characterizing guts and puck
as well as fleshing out the wider world
and its mechanics for us as an audience
now that those introductions are done
it's time to settle into the first
substantial miniak of the story one that
i noticed may have heavily influenced an
anime i saw a few years ago so obviously
in fact that i'd find it hard to believe
that they aren't at the very least
influenced either by each other or by
the same source it can't be a
coincidence but yeah i'll make sure to
mention that when i get there but for
now this story kicks off in a very
western fashion as our lone ranger guts
encounters a tyrannical vindictive and
seemingly careless count after he enters
his town
yeah
this count isn't a great leader after
having finished this arc looking back i
think it's interesting to see how many
parallels were being set up right from
the get-go between the count and guts
respectively subtle as they are i think
it helped to build up what eventually
became a similarity between them as well
as a powerful theme in this story
exploring what lengths people will go to
in order to deal with pain
loss and suffering on a plot front
there's some interesting set pieces that
really made this feel distinct to a lot
of the other scenarios we've encountered
leading up everything else before now i
realize was just training wheels and i
say this because once we learned the
count's true intentions and physical
makeup i was greeted by imagery that
actually made me wince with how
disgusting and horrific everything
looked primarily once the count starts
possessing people and growing his
slug-like slimy body inside them like
some sort of weird parasite what so okay
remember what i spoke about this are
clearly being inspired or maybe
inspiring a specific anime i watched
well it all came to my attention in the
third chapter of the guardian of desire
within which there's an image that looks
very reminiscent of numerous shots from
the parasite the maxim franchises
monster so close in fact that i'm
convinced this is where parasite guy got
his idea from but i'm not certain that's
the case both this manga and parasite
came out at roughly the same time and
given that both share such similar
imagery with this concept one is either
emulating the other or they both saw the
same inspiration from a third party
elsewhere either way it's a cool as hell
shot and one that's remained in my
memory since long after from a
choreography standpoint the fight scenes
in this arc just get better and better
by building on the prior material in the
story throughout this story we've been
introduced to the series of different
weapons in guts's arsenal like the giant
fridge to i mean
big sword uh his concealed crossbow and
to my surprise this massive explosive
flamethrower on his wrist and yes it's
as awesome as it sounds and through two
primary plot threads in this arc we're
shown the depths of what godz is capable
of and what makes the count tick is he
100 evil or is there something or
someone that he cares about from a
narrative standpoint i like how they
handle the nuance of the count's
dwindling humanity naturally he's a
despicable monster that locks his own
child away from the world but he's still
a father that while making horrific
decisions here and there and everywhere
also more or less is coming from a place
of love and fear of losing that love and
while it doesn't justify it it at least
humanizes him somewhat and as he
possesses his subordinates and fights
with guts in gripping confrontations
like small close quarter exchanges in
cellars or up staircases he becomes more
and more of a monster both figuratively
and physically with his very design
reflecting that simultaneously thanks to
puck that horror is balanced through
lighthearted carefully exposed insight
into the daughter's life or lack thereof
but before we proceed there's still one
more character i haven't mentioned and
his name is vargas effectively he serves
the narrative purpose of highlighting
the counts cruelty and guts's increasing
ambivalence towards justice vargas is
introduced to the story early on after
guts runs into trouble in the town by
bailing him out of a dicey situation
he's disfigured poor and like many
others had tragedy befalled him and his
family by way of the count's cruelty and
he also has this weird egg face thing
that gotz has a lot of interest in more
on that in just a second though at every
turn guts refuses to avenge his family
and to take down the count even after
vargas's execution which offered up some
brilliantly effective moments to
demonstrate gutz's mindset versus how
he's trying to feel it's an aspect of
this arc i thoroughly enjoyed watching
how he keeps trying to be something he's
not he tries to be detached cold and
dispassionate he tries to tell himself
this lies so often that it directly
results in the execution of vargas the
man that reached out to him when he
needed help despite trying to distance
himself from his own humanity guts's
disappointment and frustration rises he
cares but doesn't want to he doesn't
want to hurt more than he already does
so he tells himself this useful fiction
that strength is the only thing that
matters and that the weak mean nothing
in order to continue living in relative
peace of mind and as the circumstances
worsen eventually he finds a way of
tackling the issue he vows to kill the
count again lying to himself that it's
for no other apparent reason than that
he wants to or perhaps needs to be a
certain way to think that had he managed
to reconcile the sight of himself
earlier vargas could have been saved
it's the first in what i bet will become
a long list of consequences for guts to
live with the eventual fight however
that takes place is brilliant in its own
right taking elements we've learned
about guts and placing him in a
situation where his back is very
literally and figuratively up against a
wall under pressure is where we learn
what characters are capable of and
interestingly gut shows how perceptive
he is by taking the counts one weakness
his daughter theresa hostage in the heat
of battle there's some terrific imagery
that superbly communicates how
bloodthirsty he can bring himself to be
but i think this mode of action works
for guts because he recognizes what it
is about the count that he feels he
understands he believes the count won't
attack his daughter and finally speaking
more broadly i just love how weird this
story gets just when i thought that gods
had defeated the count there and then
they all go to another dimension thanks
to that weird egg thing i mean we've
gone i would argue on a steady
progression from what appeared to be an
angry man with a big sword in a medieval
setting to a full-on dark fantasy epic
complete with dimensional demons and an
angry man with a big sword that also has
a troubled backstory this miniark within
the greater black swordsman arc is
hugely entertaining it provides a
culmination of what little exposition
we've been given about the character of
guts up until this point and the
antagonist he's facing in the count
highlights a similarity between the two
of them but in doing so brings to the
forefront the greatest difference they
share while each of their respective
outlooks and decisions are made out of
fear doubt and a host of negative issues
in the face of overwhelming sadness as
well as emotional and physical torment
the count in the past chose the easy
option to remove his humanity to numb
the pain and loss of his wife whereas
guts chose to live with it and uses it
as fuel to drive him on to do the great
things that we've seen him demonstrate
with him throughout this arc having many
ups and downs successes and shortcomings
ultimately resulting in his defeated
limp body resting on the floor yet even
in the face of what must be overwhelming
pain depicted through his broken fingers
and dangling limbs he's still as
tenacious as ever gets up ever
struggling ever pushing towards freedom
freedom from his circumstances and
freedom i'd wager at this point from
whatever is haunting him in his past if
that isn't inspirational i don't know
what is okay so now that we're in this
weird demon dimension we're greeted by
the council of evil looking characters
with the preceding scenes serving to
emphasize for us the slippery slope such
thinking like the count has implemented
brings him having already done the
unthinkable to his wife before he is now
destined for hell he's owned by the
demons making it even easier to commit
the same heinous acts again to his
daughter however this is emphasized
instead to amplify our appreciation for
the count's ultimate sacrifice he loved
his daughter too much to give her up for
his own sake the little humanity that
remained was enough to make the right
decision it should go without saying
also that the visuals during this
section are spectacular with the
highlight being the wide shot of the
dimension and the souls reaching out of
hell and grabbing a hold of the count
himself vargas and all however in what i
anticipate will become typical berserk
fashion the count story ends by reaching
out one last time for his daughter's
hand a request denied specifically and
drawn attention to before in the story
and throughout their relationship always
denied before this time however
shocked by the situation and what's come
to light she for the first time reaches
back but it's too late his time is up
poetic and beautifully tragic after that
we get a terrific glimpse at what i
assume will be the big bad for the
foreseeable future someone that to guts
seems to be a familiar face confirmed
through flashbacks to their time spent
to soldiers what i love about that
inclusion to the story is what it
offered by way of once again visual
direction and exposition instead of
telling us how they feel about each
other we're shown taking all of this
demonic glitz and glamour out of the
equation and we have a story concerning
the relationship between two men one
where once upon a time he tried to help
guts up to his feet after battle but now
he quite literally is beating him to the
ground insisting he stay there we don't
get much from this exchange and in
reality i don't know much about this
dynamic yet but if guts's relentless
grit and determination carries him to
his feet when he is nothing left at all
in a last-ditch effort to get a clean
shot on this guy it made me more than a
little interested in how the
relationship has spawned this reaction
between them interestingly in the same
way many games begin by showing you how
weak you are berserk's introductory arc
reminds guts how weak he is and by
extension how trapped he really is
haunted by his branded reminder and if
it ended there i'd have been happy if it
ended there it would have been a fitting
conclusion to what the story had been
trying to achieve but that wasn't enough
for berserk after this scene it decided
to drop one more a scene that i think
provided the most powerful note in all
of the arc throughout this review you
might have noticed that i've at every
opportunity praised what i believe to be
berserk and quintaro miora's greatest
attributes their dedication to
consistent character writing and
devotion to visual storytelling and in
this final scene we get both of those in
spades after narrowly escaping the
strange demonic dimension and having
witnessed the death of the count just
three individuals remain in a room
together the devastated theresa a
confused puck and guts just about
managing a hobble aided by his sword
acting as a crutch an apt to use for the
instrument we have learned alleviated
his suffering before through action and
while our eyes are initially drawn to
guts and his wounds the grief of theresa
quickly takes hold having witnessed the
horrific scenes mere moments ago
tragically she feels no other way to
deal with these feelings contemplating
taking her own life puck ever the
compassionate voice tries to comfort her
but nothing seems to work she's heard
and seen too much horror to ever be the
same again and that's when we get guts
chiming in offering her a dagger she's
now inches from doing so before the
ground gives way beneath her clutching
for life she grasps at gutz's sword
bleeding from her fingers she climbs
back up now ironed with renewed fire in
her heart a hatred for guts claiming
that this was all his fault and that she
will one day
kill him guts staggers off laughing with
a cocky demeanor until she's out of
sight soon after his face crumbles to
end the chapter and the ark having
granted theresa the means with which to
liberate herself from her one time
prison what a stupendously
orchestrated scene climaxing with a
telling revelation not only informing us
of how compassionate guts truly is but
also further pointing us towards the
reality that gut shares more in common
with this young girl than she even
thinks taking themes from this arc and
concentrating them into one magnificent
gut punch that honestly left me
teary-eyed and excited for more before
starting this review i knew virtually
nothing about berserk as a story in my
head i worried it would be an
action-heavy narrative light affair
indulging its readers on a very
rudimentary and shallow level with
little at all to say i was wrong what i
discovered was a lovingly composed
tortured introduction to a fascinating
story detailing themes of hope fear and
tragedy penned by one of the most
impressive manga artists i've read the
work of thank you all for recommending
me this story rest in peace kantara
meora i can't wait to sink my teeth into
more of your material the funny thing is
i didn't even know at the time that the
best arc of storytelling i'd ever read
in my life is right around the corner in
the golden age
[Music]
surging back into the past with the
blink of an eye we come to learn exactly
how guts became the person he is today
outlining a chilling tale dealing with
powerful themes of abuse relationships
and one's own struggle to find their
place in the world this story is a work
of art that while passionate in its
creation and telling paints its most
vibrant colors not with traditional
tools but with the more deviant
grotesque and contorted aspects of its
subject matter humanity holding a mirror
up to society as we view the early life
of our main hero creating moments where
i left for my seat with joy grabbed this
comically sized book and squeezed it but
above all else it captured my attention
from chapter one and never let go it's
difficult to know where to start with
this review as there's an incredible
amount to discuss and analyze but i
think the best place to start this
review is chronologically with the
introduction of guts to this big
and bad world
the prologue the material covered in
this section details guts's early
childhood in hindsight while this can be
seen as the prologue to the eventual
epic that begins once griffith arrives
much like our own childhood many of the
events in this portion some mundane and
other shocking help aid us in better
empathizing and understanding berserk's
characters when you start from the
beginning of a character's life like
this i've discovered it offers many
ideal opportunities for elegant and
telling pieces of dialogue specifically
because we've already spent a
considerable amount of time with the
character in his later life forcing the
explicit and even the subtly implicit
moments to stand out to us all the more
for instance something i found
interesting right off the bat concerning
golden age was that for a decent amount
of its introduction guts doesn't say
anything in fact his first piece of
dialogue in this arc comes long after he
should be able to speak as a child and
it's not something he offers without
antagonization growing up in a band of
mercs his mother after dying and his
only father figure abusive in the middle
of a sword training session the
onlookers in the band jeer why don't you
use a sword more your size and after
being thrown to the floor guts
passionately exclaims
no dotted throughout this first chapter
covering his life from birth to nine
years of age were offered small windows
into intimate and character defining
moments in his life like this some as
explicit as his proclivity for large
weaponry poetically gripping them
tightly for security amidst the harsh
and damaging upbringing or other more
subtle familiar actions like choosing to
be there for his mom when she was
passing away even from that young of an
age he was willing to take the more
difficult option because
it meant something to someone he cared
for that really paints all of this
introduction the events that he endures
before the age of 10 are painfully human
with some of the absolute worst aspects
of our species laid to bear it is
horrific what happens to this child to
say the least and helps inform me how he
sees the world in the present day i've
certainly had times where as a child
i've been convinced of one thing that an
adult has said and has successfully
concealed the truth and as we look on
almost exclusively through guts's point
of view after having been told gambino
his father figures sold him off for the
night authorizing this heinous act it
makes their encounter afterwards all the
more unsettling and from a narrative
point of view
interesting the most interesting aspect
of this prologue comes through the
dissection and destruction of the only
relationship guts has in gambino
something i try to reliably do as a
reader is to constantly be aware of what
point of view i'm seeing certain events
through what we're implicitly told can
be as important or more important than
explicit information particularly when
it comes to coloring different
characters there are at least two
significant events where we are shown
that gambino is directly involved on the
page a particular training session with
guts and his drunken attempted murder of
the young man to cap things off gambino
is cruel emotionally bankrupt and he's
all guts has in the world with his only
substantial interactions coming by way
of battle or training for battle we see
firsthand why swords and battle are the
coping mechanisms guts has shown a
preference for and as guts gets revenge
on his attacker gambino loses his leg
and the years drift on by until we hit
the climax to this prologue a climax
that hit like a train drunk he
eventually admits that he did accept
payment for the heinous act committed
unto guts earlier in his life admission
that he hates him and in that same
breath attacks guts launching forward
with his sword
[Music]
running for his life terrified and after
suffering a tremendous fall the chaotic
nature of this manga finally relents
unveiling panels around these quiet
intimate moments that are nothing short
of breathtaking don't get me wrong i
love miura's big action set pieces too
but there's nothing i enjoy more than
his tranquil pieces more personal
moments gut shares with us as readers
and throughout this arc my favorite
illustrations from miura are not the
action heavy or horrific renderings of
the epic are fierce they aren't the
shocking or the scaring but instead the
tranquil the peaceful beauty that can be
found amidst the most chaotic of
misfortunes
band of the falcon
this is it the section were introduced
to griffith and the group of adolescent
mercenaries he leads after a dominant
performance in a village earning him
some serious coin guts begins making his
way out of town when he's attacked by a
group of griffith's crew members this is
the inciting incident that leads guts
and griffith down one of the most
interesting journeys i've experienced in
manga it seems at this point there's a
clear pecking order with kaska being the
number two to griffith's clear and far
away number one this is a leader while
young is seen almost as a god by those
in his dead and once guts wakes up
partially recovered from his previous
injuries courtesy of griffith himself we
get a short tour around the camp getting
introduced to the rest of the band but
all of that is small potatoes compared
to this
guts versus griffith the fight that
takes place between griffith and guts is
spectacular beyond measure and i will be
using it to structure this particular
review from a design point of view i
love how these two characters are
effectively polar opposites of each
other guts is rough around the ages
emotional with dark features while
griffith is calm and smooth with fair
delicate features you can tell
everything you need to know about these
two characters just by looking at their
swords and how they wield them guts with
two hands attacks aggressively charging
forward while griffith parries the
oncoming attacks from guts while only
using one hand on his weapon and when it
comes to the makeup of their blades
we're greeted with even more information
guts uses a large hunk of iron while
griffith a far more dignified and
modestly sized blade with some flashy
trimming on the hilt i love attention to
details like this it's a superbly
stunning design everything from their
opposing colored clothes to their hair
and even their faces that they make
during the fight guts's grimace
contrasted heavily by the composed and
almost emotionless expression of
griffith from a visual perspective this
fight even in its opening exchanges has
more working in its favor than so so
many others and given that i know what
the relationship amounts to later seeing
this first proper clash i was extremely
invested and i haven't even mentioned
the best part of the fight the actual
fight this altercation was made with the
understanding that if guts kills
griffith he goes free and if griffith
wins then guts will be his understanding
these consequences watching as griffith
expertly evades and makes guts look like
an amateur was nerve-racking but no
matter how much griffith pushes guts
guts would always dig even deeper and
never said die this comes to a head
however when after a massive swing of a
sword griffith composed as ever leaps
onto gutz's blade having closed the
distance and placed himself in a
victorious position blade pointed
squarely at the throat of guts he asks
forgot to surrender and he refuses ever
defiant he declares i'll show you how
mouths should be used in a fight this
was the single most cathartic moment in
the manga that i've experienced so far
watching as griffith's holier than thou
ass was thrown to the ground with guts
laying a few good hits into boot this
only further bonded me to the tenacious
and sympathetic personality that is
guts of berserk the dialogue in this
section is spectacular with griffith at
one point holding up guts's sword saying
it's an amazing sword i could never
wield it if we want to for a second
speak thematically this could mean a
number of things but because the sword
represents guts's only security against
the darkness in his mind then perhaps
what griffith means or what it can be
interpreted as thematically here is
griffith may not have shared a similar
past and therefore can't wield such a
burdensome weapon with even scenes that
take place as early in his life coming
with familiar lines like the way you
fight it's almost as though you're
gambling on your own life this fight
it honestly had everything from stakes
an audience can get behind compelling
character writing making in character
decisions and the best artwork and
framing the series has shown me yet this
was some top tier stuff climaxing with a
telling and thematically resonant
declaration from griffith once he
outmaneuvers and takes guts out now
you belong to me the aftermath once the
agreement was made guts became an acting
member of this young band of mercs doing
exceptionally well in his first outing
with the group earning their respect
after the trouble he caused initially
there's a scene that takes place atop
the castle tower that i'd like to
address and i might be reading into it a
little much but i'm a big fan of these
quiet character moments and there might
be something worth reading into in this
scene right after his first day making a
splash a parody is held for guts in his
honor reluctant to join in even when
dragged down he always feels most
comfortable when he's left alone
oftentimes in the past even when he
first picked up by this group he sits
with his back to something and his sword
held closely in this instance guts
chooses to sit atop the castle in a
similar fashion but what really caught
my attention more than anything else was
this pose he struck the morning after
sting atop the castle talking to judo
this is a strange pose and from a body
language point of view it makes sense
for him to take this guarded position
considering the subject matter they're
covering in this conversation is a
little personal but i think it could
mean a little more than that he's
covering a specific part of his face
around his nose the scar that lingers
and was etched onto his character design
was given to him by his abusive father
figure after he lashed out at him i
wonder if perhaps miura drew guts in
this scene with judo touching his scar
because unlike the place where he grew
up yearning for something somewhere to
call home in this band of young
mercenaries he might actually find
family in his mind he feels like he
perhaps might have something here and
once the subject turns to griffith again
he immediately clutches his sword once
more to end things the chapter and
glimpse of this time period in gutz's
life comes to a close in a rather
remarkable way with him happy after
achieving a believable friendship now
with some select members of the group
and with him starting to on some level
bring his walls down guts still an
adolescent now in command of his own
small group can look into the future
optimistically perhaps but i'd be remiss
if i didn't mention one final aspect of
this section that caught my attention
that i think is majorly important moving
forward the declaration griffith made
citing that he wants a kingdom and that
guts belongs to him having read the
prior material one of the themes
emphasized and explored in great detail
was that of freedom and the lengths one
would go
specifically guts to retain that freedom
during the black swordsman arc guts
valued freedom above all else and i
don't think i need to be a genius to put
two and two together here in this
instance something's gonna happen
now it's about at this time in my script
writing process i realized that if i
were to proceed like this through the
events of the story the video in
question would be about 90 minutes long
and i would be repeating myself ad
nauseum and due to this fact i was faced
with a difficult decision to make how
should i structure this how do i tackle
this massive story and then i ask myself
what were the most important aspects of
this story and my answer the characters
something i think is important to
mention at this point is that i
recognize the significance of nosferatu
zot the battle for doldry and the
absence of demonic creatures throughout
this review of the story however having
come from the black swordsman arc set
after this we saw all sorts of strange
creatures one after another the
significance of these aspects or lack
thereof in this story i thought would be
better suited for the second part of
this golden age review as i think
dividing zod's prophecy between two
videos could get a little messy so rest
assured i will be talking about that in
the next berserk review from this point
on i'd like to go a little more abstract
with my approach to this review and talk
specifically about the themes and
dynamics of different characters that
drive this section of the story towards
its conclusion starting with griffith
griffith is an astonishingly brilliant
character to structure this entire story
around as i mentioned before in my
dissection of his and gotz's first jewel
he is pitch perfect in both how he's
handled and what he says in this story
if ever i saw a character whose dynamic
gave a particular story everything they
possibly could griffith would fit that
billing to a t the means with which
miora introduces and builds this
character up over the course of the
narrative is not only enjoyable but also
creates suspense in a sense it's
difficult to discuss griffith in any
meaningful capacity without referring to
his effect on other people in the
greater story stories are after all
normally about conflict typically
between two or more characters but
griffith more so than any character in
this story has the makeup of his
character delivered almost exclusively
through how he speaks and how others
view him throughout the entirety of this
story that i've read for the purposes of
this video from the beginning to the
morning of departure chapter 3 virtually
no internal dialogue is given to us as
readers from griffith's perspective now
many of you at this point might be
saying
so who cares if we don't see his
internal yammerings what does that
matter well it matters primarily because
this arc deals with the interpersonal
relationships between many different
characters many of which include
griffith as a primary player and without
his internal monologue to let us as
viewers into understanding what he's
honestly thinking it achieves elegantly
and precisely just the right dynamic
that allows this arc to work as well as
it does it gives us all the information
we need but doesn't tell us what to do
with that information off the back of
the prologue the cast surrounding guts
explodes as we get to know the band of
the hawk through the likes of casca judo
carcass pippin rickard etc but notice
how i didn't mention griffith while
griffith plays an enormous role in the
success of this arc we don't really at
any point get to know him like we do the
other characters and certainly not in
the same level as we do with the likes
of casca and guts we do receive quiet
moments with just griffith and guts from
time to time but the only reason i'm
sure of those instances is due to
griffith scarcity in the narrative let's
take these scenes for example there are
a number of scenes where guts and
griffith talk and where griffith even
talks with others in his follow but we
never see what he's actually thinking we
only ever really receive speculation
from guts and with increasing frequency
the larger group constantly praising
griffith at first as a great leader a
warrior until he reaches goal after goal
after goal in which people then start to
refer to him as otherworldly or godlike
and this positioning the narrative
places griffith in the story is
primarily what drives the suspense
moving forward we know what griffith
wants we know what his goal is and we
know what he's willing to do to achieve
these ends but we have no idea what he's
really thinking that's what makes this
scene from the assassin chapter so
interesting to me in essence it's a
small portion of story centered around
general julius's jealousy of the newly
appointed griffith and as has been the
case with many of the other stories in
this arc both griffith and guts play
leading roles there's an entire panel
dedicated to the conflict in guts's mind
and in fittingly poetic fashion at the
chapter's climax having been assigned by
griffith to kill those that would do him
harm in addition to killing his target
and the slimy general julius he also
kills julius's son following the
secondary order of leaving no witnesses
now he didn't know that this was a kid
let alone his when he killed him but it
was a magnificent example of guts
mindlessly following someone because he
believed in him perhaps more than anyone
else in the world which makes you wonder
would he have done anything he asked and
if that's true then has guts really sold
his soul to this man griffith completely
does he really belong to him was what
griffith said when he won the jewel
entirely true then aside from the
clearly morally reprehensible acts gutz
is committing on his allies behalf
where's this sense of conflict we feel
in the story coming from well throughout
this story we felt guts gravitate
towards this group reluctantly we felt
the sense of family begin to foster
within him as well as the comrades he
goes into battle with in battles with
terrifying monsters we've seen griffith
put his life on the line time and again
in the name of saving guts from certain
death with him saying two guts his face
do i need a reason each time i put
myself in harm's way for your sake and
now after climbing out of the sewer like
a rat
leaving a trail of death in his wake
guts looking to speak with what he would
consider a friend stands at the base of
a large staircase as both him and casca
watch on as griffith sitting atop a
stairs out of reach discusses philosophy
with the princess he's courting ending
with the most biting quote of all
highlighting how single-minded he is in
his vision his conquest and never-ending
pursuit to his one goal of his when
asked directly about his friends or
troop he says something to the princess
that sets the wheels in motion for what
will become his downfall in this section
of the story he says they are excellent
troops together we have faced death so
many times they are valuable comrades
devoting themselves to the dream i
envision but to me a friend is something
else someone who would never depend upon
another's dream someone who wouldn't be
compelled by anyone but would determine
and pursue his own reason to live and
should anyone trample that dream he
would oppose him body and soul even if
the threat were me myself what i think a
friend is is one who is my equal as
readers having been forced to contend
with the moral ambiguity of the main
character's violent actions knowing full
well he wishes for a relationship with
griffith and knowing that he didn't
enjoy doing what he did that night we
have to watch guts hear digest and
understand that statement from griffith
encapsulated beautifully and as
succinctly as anything i've seen by the
following page highlighting just how
many levels of difference there are both
physically and figuratively between
those two characters the hired assassin
fresh from the sewer acting on someone
else's behalf without question and the
clean and dignified visionary who
pursues with unwavering focus towards
his ultimate dream such poetry we do not
normally see in manga and now
we have direct conflict spawning from a
desire born from guts's childhood and
trauma what an astonishingly great scene
there's absolutely more i want to
discuss regarding this character but for
now let's move on to another for a brief
moment casca casca is the third spoke on
this narrative wheel alongside guts and
griffith with respect to guts and
griffiths she represents gutz's
relationship with the band of the hawk
acts as a bridge to griffith during
numerous conversations for guts and
perhaps most crucially she represents
and highlights how the broader band of
the hawk and all who fall under
griffith's spell praise adulate and
glorify him creating a man bigger than
legend itself further serving and
leaning into the composed deification
for lack of a better term that griffith
seems to want to promote around him
while and this is my speculation
leveraging the trauma and yearning for
acceptance these forgotten toys of the
wider berserk world cry out for in his
stead clearly as made evident by the
contents of this video review berserk
and more specifically this arc is
centered around two characters in
griffith and guts however there's a
fascinating section of the story which
allows casca to take center stage and to
no longer play the seldom seen secondary
character role she has been following up
until this point it all begins in the
day of the big battle against the white
whale knights and as a quick aside every
action this band takes is to the end of
elevating not only themselves but
primarily griffith as he works his way
from lowly commoner to leader of a
mercenary group to a nice to a general
and so on and so forth and during the
events of this section we are very much
entrenched in that struggle for
elevation and promotion one of the most
significant themes following the
character of kaska is one of acceptance
tying wonderfully into guts's sense of
worthlessness she now during this
significant battle starts to find sudden
difficulty due to her own natural
biological complications that set her
apart from this old-fashioned world of
men reminding her that despite her
decision to live like a man there are
some things that can't be avoided and
this same aspect offer leads to guts
someone who's constantly nagging and
poking fun at her for being a girl
however thanks to the time they spend
together he soon realizes and grows to
appreciate and admire how much more
difficult and tough it must be to be a
woman warrior in this instance citing
her as above all the other weaklings at
the reception following the battle
showing a true sign of respect on his
behalf their budding relationship
platonic or otherwise for me was a
phenomenal secondary plot thread which
contrasts her extreme and limitless
admiration for griffith with her natural
and organic relationship with guts the
history that's an earth concerning her
past as well as the bond she reluctantly
forms with a person she at one point
hated for reasons i'll get into in just
a sec guts was both symbolically
beautiful as all miura works normally
are but it also illuminated a dynamic
that i wasn't aware of being one of the
main characters involved in guts's
recruiting we get to see her side of the
story as she admits to at one point in
time hating guts bringing to light the
reason behind her constant frustrations
and anger towards him over the years
revealing a damaging backstory and
unhealthy admiration for griffith and a
lack of appreciation for guts as well as
those around her by extension in essence
i felt as though while reading these
chapters the more kaska got to know and
interact with guts the more the two of
them gained the deeper understanding of
themselves the more deeper appreciation
and empathy for each other they felt
placed in high-risk scenarios as guts
single-handedly slaughters 100 men all
by himself in the name of buying her
time and to get help but also for
another reason i want to touch on in
just a sec once they return to the site
where she last saw guts fighting for his
life we see bodies strewn across the
land as guts holding himself up with the
help of a tree and his trusty sword
stands victorious there have been a
number of instances throughout the story
where godz has run into trouble on his
own causing griffith to put his life on
the line for his sake leading to casca's
hatred for how careless guts can be and
jealousy as to why she can't be cared
for like that by griffith after the
entire outing takes place and resolves
itself she gets what she wanted for
griffith to outwardly state that she is
a valued member and while she does get
that we as readers also see firsthand
that despite griffith having had nothing
to do with this achievement from guts
despite guts getting praised for his
monumentous undertaking others still use
this as an opportunity to highlight how
amazing griffith is in comparison if
guts is this good imagine how amazing
griffith could be this has been
something that's been alluded to
numerous times and while i was aware of
it this was the moment it cemented for
me my feelings on the griffith character
campfire of dreams campfire of dreams is
my favorite chapter in all of the manga
that i've read so far this is the single
most touching and spectacularly
beautiful chapter i think i've ever read
in my life all the while highlighting
exactly what it is about this story that
makes it so special to me there's no
fighting there's no dynamic action
sequences there's no violence it's just
a quiet moment two friends share from a
familiar distance to the night's
festivities as guts for what feels like
the first time decides to speak his mind
and let someone else in and know how he
feels he begins revealing how he wasn't
fighting back there to protect her
against those 100 enemies but instead
did so in essence because it's who he
thinks he is it's what comes naturally
and highlights how he has nothing else
in his life he admires kaska and
griffith for feeling so strongly about
their dreams and that due to the
discrepancy between them he feels
alienated even when looking down at all
the individual lights painted across the
land in his honor his dream whether he
wants it to be or not isn't here with
these people and taking what griffith
said to heart he wants to fight tooth
and nail to find something he can live
to die for much like the rest of this
arc it's a 10 out of 10 but because it
resonated with me so powerfully i needed
to dedicate a small bit of this video's
run time to it but the main takeaway
guts is leaving and it'll be after the
next campaign the morning departure this
is a special section of storytelling for
me and figuring out a way to effectively
describe what i felt while reading has
been the cause for many re-drafts of
this particular video essays review
there have been certain iconic scenes
i've read through that have taken my
breath away whether it be through
childhood or my adult life i've looked
back at all of these in retrospect and
was able to on some level figure out how
they in fact pulled off what made them
so special to me and what makes this
particular scene all the more impactful
for me anyway is that despite the
largest and most impressive battle
taking place in the form of the battle
to claim tudor stronghold the battle
while impressive and yet again
containing many story beats concerning
guts kaska and griffith respectively it
is but a footnote in my mind compared to
one of the single best rematches in all
of japanese storytelling that i've seen
personally guts versus griffith round
two i think for me what made this
particular encounter so earth-shattering
came in two waves the first being the
least impressive narratively so let's
get that out of the way first up until
this point there has been a considerable
and measured approach taken when
comparing and growing the relationships
between guts and griffith the first
major confrontation between them came
about at a time when guts was much
younger less experienced and not to
mention injured however this was not
much mentioned beyond one or two passing
comments acknowledging that additionally
over the course of the time they spent
together griffith and guts haven't
exactly been short in time spent
together alone on the page sharing
moments of levity as well as deep
contemplation with guts very clearly
acting as someone griffith can confide
in however and this has been made
evident since the very beginning
griffith isn't a normal person in this
story with not a single individual
seeing him as someone that they can
build a meaningful relationship with
he's always on another level which
brings me to my favorite aspect of this
story nothing is explicitly told to us
we are left to infer for ourselves what
the relationships are or are not who is
connected to reality and who isn't casca
idolizes griffiths she wishes to quote
be his sword meaning that she wants to
be the best warrior she can so that when
the time comes she can be what griffith
needs her to be in combat to defend him
in addition to that practically every
single sentence a character utters in
this story concerning griffith holds him
in the same regard as a deity in
addition to every single last plot
element of the story being told created
with the express purpose of elevating or
protecting griffith standing helping him
to reach his overall goal of ruler which
conflicted magnificently with the
character of guts having grown to be a
mountain of a man and having grown
closer to griffith than he was with any
of the others up until now maybe
excluding casca for him to be confronted
with the notion that yet again he's
worthless compared to him and that
griffith has been using him to meet his
end all this time it must be a bitter
reality to come to terms with and when
guts decides to leave quote once again
is thrown out by griffith you belong to
me this is his mask off moment at least
for me a moment that signifies that
while everything has developed over the
last three years from their status to
their interpersonal relationships as
soldiers and comrades griffith is still
very much the exact same person who said
those words that day which brings me to
something i noticed about the dialogue
and the visuals during this section the
jewel that takes place isn't necessarily
what impresses me about this section but
the swirling of doubt in my mind that
took place during it i was ridiculously
nervous for guts during his lead up for
the first swing but now looking back i
realized that i had no reason to this is
the very first time we are as readers
allowed to see into griffith's thought
process unabated for a consistent amount
of time which allows us to see his
actual thoughts on a broader subject
unlike the first encounter we do not see
anything from guts's point of view
everything is from griffiths from the
commentary the strategy he's looking to
employ to how he's evaluating the
situation whether an environment it is
ridiculously thorough as we experience
firsthand how comprehensive and
contemplative the proficient griffith is
being bolstered in part in my mind by
the constant praise he's received all
the time leading up to this moment in my
mind
he's better than guts and when the swing
does come down so too does the world
griffith has made crumble visually i
don't think i need to explain what makes
this spectacular so i'll just dance
across my favorite aspects of it quickly
the mindset of gods is a total opposite
compared to their last with his facial
expressions and his positioning in many
panels reflecting that reality guts now
pictured higher than the once more
domineering griffith painted all across
the backdrop of a sun rising anew
symbolizing a fresh start on the morning
snow the shock that floods across
griffith's face as he drops to his knees
in utter despair when faced with the
sudden reality of his situation was
massively satisfying guts is more
powerful than griffith he's leaving and
griffith needs him i want to make clear
right now that i have absolutely zero
idea as to how this story arc will
complete but i have a feeling that
despite the horrific stuff i've seen so
far i've seen nothing yet throughout
what i've read so far i've seen in this
material griffith will do just about
anything to give himself what he needs
to succeed and i don't think he would
have made it this far if something like
this was going to stop him he's going to
retaliate but i have no idea how
i've never read berserk before but
kantara miura's sophomore outing in
golden age utterly broke me berserk's
golden age is a prequel story about how
the series main protagonist guts became
the man he is in the present day
following him from his literal birth
until the lowest moments of his life in
essence this is guts's backstory and in
my opinion is easily the best origin
i've come across in recent memory in the
first part of this i explored what
turned out to be the upbeat section of
this tale as we observed the complex
relationships and dynamics organically
forming around the main cast of
characters suddenly experiencing a
fissure unlike anything i've seen before
in manga a fissure not driven by hatred
or anger but of ambition and hope advice
taken on board with the story in
question ending in one of the most
hopeless and horrifying places i think i
may ever read or see and what happens
between these two moments in time is one
of the best examples of character-driven
storytelling and character torture i've
seen put to paper and indeed one of the
greatest if not the greatest narrative
performance in all of manga that i've
read and i'm not afraid to say that
better than anything i've seen presented
by dragon ball hunter hunter jojo or
indeed one piece if you've ever
expressed an interest in learning how to
write compelling or exciting stories
with complex characters and motivations
berserk's 1997 climax to the golden age
arc is something to be studied
[Music]
speaking of someone that reviews anime
and manga for a living something i
routinely have to contend with is the
relentless amount of fan service in
these stories often times i get it sex
sells and all but at the end of the day
to me it feels like a crutch or at the
very least an annoying distraction that
takes from what i'm really interested in
the story which is of course why i
watched keijo kintara miura on the other
hand is something of a savant when it
comes to writing these types of scenes
instead of feeling bored or annoyed by
tired and overdone tropes getting in the
way of the story i'm instead captivated
by these scenes as they not only enhance
the story but they are essential in
exposing us to integral and emotionally
revealing character differences
something that's abundantly clear in
berserk's golden age arc is that it's
centered around not just one character
or a group of characters necessarily but
a set of relationships and how they
contrast in subtle and stark fashion
with the two main relationships explored
after this jewel being guts and casca
and griffith and charlotte and what i
thought these scenes achieved perhaps
above all else was their highlighting of
the existing differences between guts
and griffith as well as their approach
to their respective encounters once
their deal concludes both guts and
griffith albeit at different times have
to face the consequences of their
actions griffith now has to face a
soul-crushing trip back to reality and
guts has to reconcile what became of his
friends after his decision in other
words both guts and griffith's
characters are exposed to a tremendous
amount of pressure and that's important
one of the most important techniques to
make use of as a writer is one that
allows you to communicate to your
audience who your characters are in a
believable fashion much the same as real
life someone's true character is only
revealed under pressure i've mentioned
this before but author professor and
story consultant robert mckee put it
best in his book entitled story true
character is revealed in the choices a
human being makes under pressure the
greater the pressure the deeper the
revelation the truer the choice to the
character's essential nature these
high-stakes high-pressure scenes are in
essence what turns otherwise boring
characters into fan favorites villains
heroes or otherwise take for example
disney's the lion king
alright okay i can see you all rolling
your eyes from here but really
techniques and storytelling are present
across all genres even ones as different
as berserk and the lion king in this
film simba is introduced as a headstrong
naive and in many ways arrogant kid
impatiently waiting for his time in the
sun as king of the pride lands to begin
at this point as an audience we have no
reason to care for him as a character
necessarily we appreciate he's a kid
he's cute and he has some great parents
but he's not proven himself to us and so
that's where this scene comes in the
elephant graveyard in this simba drags
his friend nala into a life or death
situation thanks to his own inability to
see the woods from the trees but in the
elephant graveyard despite being
terrified and in way over his head simba
still goes back to save nala against
those monsters he knows can kill him
this is the moment we as fans of the
lion king learn to respect and
appreciate simba's character and it's
one of the many reasons why the live
action remake fails in capturing that
same magic because they cut that scene
out of the film now we have no reason to
like simba and as a result the film
feels hollow and i labor that point for
one specific reason it's the very
technique miura's perfected the
technique that turned guts from a
character we appreciate to one we
despair
hope and pray for in the end following
that crushing defeat during his duel
with guts griffith shaken to his very
core feeling like he's lost control of
everything in his life grabs the nearest
branch on his fall down to reality and
in a desperate attempt to seize control
of something he forces himself onto
princess charlotte in a fashion never
before seen by us in the series it's
incredibly uncomfortable but it's also
the most human this one time god among
men has ever appeared to us even after
the fact he feels hollow and alone left
holding himself distraught it's an
effective scene for all the reasons i
outlined but to add further layers to
this outcome as touched on prior this
scene is also a terrific contrast that
brings the best out of what transpires
between guts and casca with griffith's
relationship with charlotte being born
out of manipulation leverage and
ambition guts and caskets develop
naturally across the entire ark he
encounters her even before he does
griffith and i don't think there's a
single person guts himself interacts
with more in significant ways maybe judo
is a close candidate but even then
that's mostly light conversation unlike
griffith who sought out charlotte for
his own selfish desires after having
left for a long time guts returns into
casket's life not for personal
indulgence but instead to make a save in
grand fashion he learns of all the
hardships she's had to endure and how
strong she's been for everyone involved
this is a far cry from griffith scene
with charlotte and the differences only
pile up as the story progresses where
griffith barely spoke to charlotte even
cutting her off mid-sentence with an
unsolicited kiss gutz and casca work
through the remaining differences and
baggage together in one of the most
beautifully vulnerable and powerful
scenes so far in the story
metaphorically laying themselves bare
before each other this is what genuine
connection looks like and it's exactly
what cuts has been looking for all story
long and during this waterfall scene
there's a specific moment where we as an
audience finally see the toll this past
year has had on casca's site and we see
the state the band of the hawk has been
reduced to and from the deepest despair
guts himself helps to uplift her from
this courageous self-imposed prison and
in no greater contrast to griffith
instead of forcing himself on her he
gently and slowly comforts her naturally
leading to their first kiss it's a
gorgeous marriage of narrative
competence and masterful layout work
right here if the story ended i would
have been happy
but it didn't
the rescue of griffith courtesy of the
best the band of the hawk has to offer
is such a thrilling and anxious affair
there are so many different plot threads
dangling in the air with some
stupendously subtle paneling implemented
to foreshadow future events that i could
hardly contain myself throughout my
reading furthermore i really appreciate
how this ragtag team of rescuers are
incredibly proficient faced with
scenarios that are far more complex than
we've ever seen before i love how
everyone from guts to casket to judo to
even pippin find their means of
contribution towards this final effort
which will no doubt make what happens
after all the more shocking and
sorrowful again continuing to implement
the techniques spoken on prior miura
places our heroes in situations they've
never before seen the likes of having to
sneak into one of the darkest most
oppressing environments we've
collectively encountered the band have
to make their way down to the cellar
where griffith has been kept all this
time as punishment for violating the
princess apart from the horrific imagery
on display during this segment something
that's particularly impressive i think
here was this page this is a wonderful
misdirection for the readers given the
candor displayed by guts and the rest of
the band it seemed to me upon first read
through that this was a tender moment
displaying two friends reuniting and
showing their appreciation for each
other however upon closer inspection and
now armed with the knowledge of what's
to come we can notice that unlike guts
griffith wasn't crying and that he in
fact wasn't trying to hug him but was
trying to strangle him when we as people
are pushing the brink our true nature is
presented and this remains true here
with griffith showing us exactly who he
is i think it's also kind of interesting
how as i mentioned in the previous video
guts a security blanket is in many ways
his sword and think there's an
interesting contrast here later in the
story griffith has a moment where he's
talking to himself about what he's done
for guts and the dangers he's put
himself in to protect him which made me
think guts was griffith's security
blanket and as soon as he lost him he
felt as if he had no control over the
world anymore like he lost a fundamental
part of himself in other words he was
put under pressure and he couldn't take
it in many ways the protagonist of this
story can only be as intellectually
fascinating or emotionally compelling as
the forces of antagonism make him in
other words a great hero can only be as
good as the forces of evil he's up
against and what i find so interesting
about that particular idea is the means
with which miura understood this rule
and chose to build upon it the strength
of a story like berserk is that it isn't
restrained by the limitations of other
manga narratives targeted towards
different demographics due to this fact
miura is free to make something look as
beautiful or as horrifying as he can
possibly imagine taking comparable
elements like these two sex scenes i
spoke on earlier making one of them
appear beautiful elegant and freeing
with this initial scene between guts and
casca showing us everything great that
can happen from an outing like this and
at the end of the arc some of the
absolute worst in a way berserk shows us
the very best and the absolute worst of
human nature and the story is all the
more powerful for it this allows him to
create those extreme pressures for
various characters i told you about
earlier and as a result makes our heroes
appear that much more legendary and
virtuous while making the antagonists
all the more underhanded and despicable
making for heavenly high highs and soul
destroying lows berserk is a manga of
extremes with the arcs beginning feeling
extremely grounded but as the story
trudges onward the more fantastical
elements make themselves known gradually
over time this is all to say that the
characters of berserk and the world of
berserk served to make this one of the
most emotionally resonant stories out
there if these techniques i've
illuminated were created to help grab a
viewer's attention then the extremes
berserk employee serves to shackle the
reader's attention to the pages as they
flutter by seamlessly
nosferatu zod and the battle of doldry
last week i neglected to speak on the
events of the battle of doldry for a
number of reasons i don't like to dwell
too much on heavy action set pieces as
they are a feast for the eyes but not
always for the mind with that taken into
consideration however the battle of
daldre gave me more than a little to
consider and sink my teeth into
particularly now that i've finished the
arc and have the benefit of hindsight
throughout this story godz has been a
man akin to hercules otherworldly
strength tenacious understanding and he
never seems to reach his limits this has
been helped on numerous occasions by the
circumstances he not only is placed in
but manages to crawl out of we've seen
him defeat monsters demons and even
armies of men all trying their very best
to take him down but none ever have
but one almost did
and it wasn't a monster or a demon or an
army it was a single man during godzi's
impressive physical display there is one
instance where for lack of a better term
or way of describing it he was supposed
to die that had it not been for one
specific character nosferatu zod guts
wouldn't be here zod makes his presence
felt numerous times throughout this arc
and always in a pivotal sense in a way
zod seems at the very least morbidly
interested in guts for what reason i
can't be certain but he is interested in
him nevertheless perhaps similar to how
hisoka treats many of the main cast
early on in hunter hunter
zod seems to be interested in preserving
the likes of guts for during the moment
he was about to die he threw him the
weapon he needed to survive at that
moment he was conflicting with our idea
of him as a character in our minds we
view him as the bad guy and now he's
preserving the life of the hero
character but knowing what i know now it
almost seems as though this was one of
the worst things he could have ever done
for this young man given his talk of the
eclipse which i will definitely speak on
in just a sec he seems to be involved in
this idea of pre-ordained destiny he
will ensure that gods will make it to
the eclipse and once branded it's only a
matter of time before he guts will lose
his life in many ways zod not only
prolongs guts's life but ensures it down
a specific path that he's interested in
and it highlighted just how vulnerable
and human the character of guts actually
is
making his character that much more
effective
the eclipse it's going to be very
difficult for me to say something
concerning this aspect of the story
beyond what many before me already have
and to a much better degree i haven't
studied this act the same way many
people have and these are really just my
first impressions but personally i found
this to be a stunningly beautiful affair
in terms of artwork while also being one
of the most difficult sections of
storytelling i've ever and i mean this
sat through in my life and it's by
design while reading this i felt really
uncomfortable however in that same
breath i cheered guts on as much as i
could this eclipse had been an event
we've effectively been counting down
towards since it was first mentioned the
link was made with that weird necklace
egg thing griffith had and really i had
been waiting to see what sort of twisted
and sadistic circumstances griffith
would put guts through to create that
same level of hatred he demonstrated at
the end of the black swordsman arc and
by the way those of you that say the
black swordsman arc is unnecessary i
think are dead wrong the ark sets up the
lens through which we are expected to
see this arc going into golden age we
know how it's going to end and the arc
is written to cater to that viewpoint
specifically skipping black swordsmen is
in my opinion a significantly worsened
experience and certainly not
inconsequential going into this arc in
the back of my mind i was on the
defensive trying to prevent the story
from making me care about these
characters because i knew there was
going to come a moment where guts would
be alone and filled with the same
resentment and vengeance we previously
saw him with but i didn't succeed in
that venture because that's exactly what
this arc tricks you into doing it tricks
you into caring much like guts is as a
character we as an audience after black
swordsman have our guards up on alert
against the outcome we know is coming
but over the course of this sprawling
epic one after another our walls come
tumbling down as we learn to embrace and
hope for the future with guts and his
new team of friends we learn to love
pippin's good nature judo's sharp and
considerate thinking carcasses abrasive
antics kaska's strength and compassion
and even maybe for a moment or two
griffith's determination like guts we
had our guard up against the evil that
we knew was coming and yet miura found a
way to help us warm to this at times
overwhelmingly cold world through this
lovable group the same way guts did
learning about their pain their
struggles and the sacrifices they've
been either forced to make or have been
apprehensively made when all other
options had been taken away from them
miura created a world populated it with
some of the most human characters we've
ever seen and in leveraging that which
we cared for he gave us exactly what
he'd made us hope never would manifest
he flooded this human world with demons
any sense of stability hope and
happiness that was once present is now
immediately extinguished in the most
excruciating of ways the pressures these
characters have been placed under has
been perhaps greater than any we've seen
during this we see who these people
really are for the better and for the
worse the term bad dream is mentioned
numerous times during this particular
apocalyptic scenario and i think it's as
if to reinforce the success of griffith
achieving his lifelong dream with it
effectively being everyone's collective
nightmare throughout berserk gutz has
been depicted as a fallible flawed
troubled but immeasurably resilient
individual capable of feats of strength
and tenacity far greater than anyone
ever expected from him the trend
throughout the story has placed him
under tremendous pressure time and again
forcing him to place his life on the
line against impossible odds showing us
that he truly is a powerful heroic and
virtuous person reinforcing this idea
that as long as he's armed he's
practically invincible in combat and so
instead of continuing that trend miura
decides to subvert this very aspect of
him during the eclipse in this miura
asks the question what if guts can't
save them what if guts fails cast it
into a literal hellscape vortex of which
there is virtually no escape the
paneling once again is some of the best
in the industry but perhaps some of the
very best out of miura himself there's a
real sense of scale and horror to these
moments helping to emphasize some of the
more tender exchanges as the main group
slowly whittle away to nothing pippin
sendoff broke my heart as he stayed back
to hold them off only for us to see him
fall in the distance carcasses ii was
nightmarish to a horrifying degree but
judo's honestly took me by surprise and
because of that it hit me like a train
watching as he time and again does
everything in his limited power to
struggle and protect casca only two on
his deathbed revealed to us as readers
he in fact always had feelings for her
made me tear up beyond belief and with
everyone dead kaska captured and guts
struggling and crawling to her rescue
once again miura puts us and guts
through hell
for almost two entire chapters were
forced to watch powerless to do anything
as the person guts loves more than
anyone in the world endures some of the
worst abuse i've ever been able to see
or think of with the artwork capturing
how guts felt more accurately than i
ever could possibly describe thanks to
miura's masterful implementation of a
calligraphy brush hacking his arm off
and piercing his eye trying to get free
unable to change anything page after
page this kept on going relentlessly so
much so i had to step away from the
story after witnessing it but upon my
return a day or two later the worst part
came into focus for me for once the
eclipse came to a close griffith rose to
power as some sort of dark phoenix
satanic demigod and skull knight saved
both guts and casca the story and
torture in a sense continues
destiny there seems to be an interesting
push to empower the idea of destiny in
some shape or form within this story
time and again noteworthy events occur
as puck and gods without even knowing
each other indirectly intersect here's
an example early in the story judo tells
kaska about the elf he met in those days
when he was working with a traveling
entertainment troupe we of course know
who he's talking about but within this
conversation he gives kaska this elf or
fairy dust that ends up healing godz's
wounds after he managed to take out 100
men this link could have ended here as a
very nice cameo but later in the story
during the events of the eclipse we
actually get to see puck cross paths
with rickert so i wonder is this
relationship between guts and puck
destined to happen are their fates
intertwined in some sort of meaningful
way what is miora trying to tell me here
because we later see rickard meeting
with guts again and as it is said in
this troop scene he's going to be
important in later events there are some
other subtle details like god's crossing
paths with account as he is the apostle
who ends up killing pippin during the
eclipse but this whole destiny concept
gets much more present towards the
conclusion of the arc where skull knight
and the demons tell guts explicitly that
he is branded and will be forever
haunted as a result and in this moment
guts fiercely declares war against his
own destiny as he believes he's the one
who blazes his own path even when the
circumstances point to everything other
than that being the reality which is
sort of ironic because guts is forced to
follow this path that seems to be
already decided by destiny he is healed
by the elf thus both zod and scotland
save his life in situations where he
should have died and most importantly he
crosses paths with griffith and griffith
specifically because it is said by both
humans and demons that he is someone
special and we see this at the end of
the eclipse guts falls into a pit that
seems bottomless while griffith rises
from the ashes like some sort of
primordial phoenix as he embraces his
true nature and his decisive victory in
this finale it's like griffith was
favored by destiny from the beginning
while guts wasn't griffith has
everything in his hands to achieve his
goals and dreams while guts has nothing
other than his sword griffith is allowed
to dream while guts
is cursed to struggle
the aftermath having been the only
person to survive that ordeal and come
out relatively unscathed guts
experiences the isolation and loneliness
that comes with the strength and
resilience he possesses for the duration
of this arc as things began to get
better and better for our main troop one
of my favorite aspects has to be the
relationship between guts and his team
but more specifically kaska their
relationship throughout was spectacular
and felt extremely real and as the
looming end came ever closer i couldn't
ignore that i knew what was going to
happen at the end of the black swordsman
arc i knew griffith would be someone he
hated more than anyone and i knew he was
alone and so as people died in grand but
horrific fashion i was faced with
something while gruesome was also
something i had anticipated a while back
on my twitter i shared some thoughts i
had regarding this series saying that i
wish that things would have stayed as
they were i tweeted this having been
convinced that kaska would die at the
end of the story along with the rest of
them but in reality something at least
for now far worse has happened the worst
thing for guts wasn't for casket
necessarily to die but for her to go on
in this tortured tortured state she's
left in and in learning how he has to
constantly keep finding a reason to live
and fight not only was beautiful but
tied once again back with that quote
griffith throughout towards the middle
of the arc guts now well he has a goal
to survive and to fight griffith body
and soul
before i go numerous messages i received
after i announced that i would be
tackling this series claimed that i
would find its contents too grim much
the same as i did with hunter hunter
during my read-through of that many of
those that messaged me said i would find
more of the same here and going into
this series i was very conscious of that
being a distinct possibility but what
berserk revealed to me wasn't
unrelenting depression but instead quite
the opposite behind the gore violence
torture and agony many in this story
have to endure resides a tale rich with
hope and love begging for someone any
one of us to just hold on that little
bit longer to keep fighting to keep
crawling to keep struggling towards a
brighter future it's one of the most
touching narratives i've ever had the
pleasure of reading and i can't
recommend this story to anyone out there
enough berserk's sophomore outing in the
golden age arc receives the highest
praise i think i can give a story i'm
excited to read it again
and again and again if you haven't yet
read it consider yourself one of the
lucky ones because you have ahead of
yourself the possibility of enjoying
something that i think comes around only
once in a lifetime so if you can go grab
yourself the work of potentially the
greatest mangaka to have ever lived
quintaro miura and let's struggle
through this incredible tale of loss
love despair and happiness as we make
our way into
the conviction art
[Music]
[Music]
the lost children arc is a story unlike
any other contained within berserk in
most other sections of this sprawling
tragedy miura allows us to view guts as
the backbone of each part however in
this guts isn't the backbone and i
wouldn't even say he's the main
protagonist in fact speaking
specifically about the foundations of
this arc no one character fulfills that
role in my view but instead what anchors
this narrative is a fairy tale of sorts
a piece of folklore that brings with it
an interesting angle for which to view
this story through so i think in order
to understand this arc you must first
understand its fairy tale peace the
outcast something that came as a shock
to me while i was reading this was how
similar the structure was to one of my
favorite one piece arcs skypia i'm not
going to spoil the story of skype yet
but one aspect that these two stories
share is the legend or fairy tale
present in their respective stories
which dictates what happens later either
thematically or literally in the case of
one piece it's the story of noland and
in the case of lost children it's the
tale of pikaf the outcast occupying
roughly two and a half pages in the
entire arc pikaf's story tells a tale of
a young village boy with two loving
parents however sporting two pointy ears
and red eyes he finds himself alienated
from the rest of his community routinely
bullied by the other children one night
however in search of his real family
picaff ran into the forest looking for
where the elves lived where grown-ups
never said to go eventually he found the
elves but not the family he was seeking
picaff didn't have wings and was
honestly quite different to the elves he
sought community with they did however
tell him that one night many many years
ago a mother and father ventured into
the woods to save their sick child they
managed to save him with their magic but
in exchange changed his appearance to
half resemble that of the elves learning
this with great haste he ran off back to
the village only to find that one
hundred years had passed in the moments
he was away left alone pcaf the outcast
cried and cried his red eyes swollen
even redder the moral of the story is
simple to understand in isolation but
it's how miura leverages this story and
explores its themes and potential
messaging in this broader story with two
of its key characters jill a young girl
rescued at the beginning by guts and
eventually another young girl called
rosine
one of the first things you'll notice in
this story is how different it feels
from all the others and it achieves this
through gutz's relinquishing his
position as the main character instead
placing this role as the young girl with
a troubled family situation called jill
and the reason i see her as the main
character is that there are large
portions of it told through her point of
view specifically for instance there's a
tremendous amount of narration
surrounding jill and guts's first
meeting when he rescues her from some
bandits and kidnappers already this sets
a different tone but what really makes
this strange is how he's often referred
to as the black swordsman or just
swordsman instead of guts his name with
this very introduction she has two guts
framed as our own to the character also
in another scene after gutz brings her
home he's shown a quiet place to rest
but when we return to that scene the
next morning we find that we didn't
spend the night with him and instead
jill it's her point of view and story
that this tale is concerned with we
return to god's having clearly spent a
night fighting monsters only for jill to
stumble upon the aftermath jill is our
point of view character guts is just the
catalyst for the chaos that ensues
immediately after this moment when we
get the first meeting between the two
main characters the protagonist jill and
the antagonist rosine interestingly and
in keeping with the story doing things
just a little bit different instead of
guts being held responsible for the
action taking place in this arc it's
hawk and his elephant appearance that's
held responsible and the reason is
obviously this girl i've been talking
about called rosine oh and by the way
did i mention that she's a weird moth
monster this is one of the two
antagonists of the ark and one of the
most important elements of the story to
our main protagonist in jill and i'd
like to talk about why this is cool now
but instead right in the middle of the
story we get this weird one shot chapter
called the prototype in the hardback
deluxe edition i'm reading berserk the
prototype this story is a submission
piece created by kantara miura during
his stay in college in 1988 which became
his basis for what is now called the
series berserk the establishment of
certain details world view and whatnot
differs at points from the berserk
series that was later published but the
intent is still present in this early
incarnation the most noticeable
difference right away is how much looser
and art style the pages and characters
are drawn with it still looks like
berserk but with a greater emphasis on
expression over the detail he would
become later known for however in
addition to that this manga carries with
it a great sin one which i i don't think
i can forgive for when guts is requested
by an old woman to avenge her
granddaughter he refuses in a way that
makes my very skin crawl confidently he
responds i've got nothing to do with
just and generous chivalry i could care
less
i can't believe you've done this to
borrow a quote from david mitchell i
could care less is absolutely useless as
an indicator of how much you care
because the only thing that it rules out
is that you don't care at all which is
exactly what you're trying to convey and
let's be clear here for one moment i
don't blame miura for a second but i do
blame whoever localized the version i'm
reading into english translation is a
tough business i'm sure but one thing
i'm supposed to be able to take for
granted when someone translates into
english is that they know how to speak
[ __ ] english
i award you no points
and may god have mercy on your soul
and now i'm realizing that i've spoken
about literally one tiny line more than
the chapter itself in broad strokes this
chapter while having a few details
changed here and there highlights how
much of the story miura was settled on
even before the story began branding's
the design of which is only minorly
changed his appearance and the eclipse
over the castle a shot that is etched
into my mind so deep i'm convinced years
of therapy won't remove it and of course
the character of puck the flavor of
berserk is very clearly present as well
as miura's approach with guts as a
character being a selfish tough guy
that's pretty bad at being selfish
decent chapter overall nothing
groundbreaking but if you're a fan of
the series you will absolutely get a
kick out of this and now back to the
main story in the past miura has
described this story and the broader
conviction arc as a sakaike or world
type story the simple definition of a
sekaike's story is the existence of a
close relationship between two people
which turns out to be the sole driving
force of the events up to and including
having all other happenings in the world
at large depending on said
relationship's fate whether
metaphorically or literally within the
broader conviction eric muir is
obviously alluding to the relationship
between guts and puck which too plays a
massive role in these events surrounding
lost children particularly the ending
but the relationship in question that
influences the path of lost children
specifically is that which exists
between the characters of jill our
protagonist and rosine her friend and
the antagonist of this story something
miura does a fantastic job of with this
chapter is managing the audience's
expectations we're made aware of
everyone's biases experiences and how
their perception of the character guts
changes and morphs over the narrative
and it's most effective when we finally
see the image of the children now
corpses in a burning barn after changing
back once they die at the hands of guts
worth noting here though is that they
actually attacked him first they weren't
children and were in fact monster bug
creatures embodied with the spirit of
children lost from the village but try
telling that to the parents they see a
pile of child corpses and all of a
sudden everyone's up in arms it's very
like kintara miura to really hammer home
just how bad a situation is by making it
stand beside significantly less
harrowing material i mean there's a page
during the chapter entitled red eye
peace where in a small fire a child
reaches out to guts asking for his mommy
and cuts just cleaves this young guy in
twain like it's really brutal stuff but
it comes immediately after seeing a
heart-to-heart with jill and puck
following close behind him jill's
recounting of a backstory concerning her
one-time friend rosine however is
interesting for a number of reasons i
really like how these brief moments of
reflection add more color to this
already black world making it feel all
the more lived in but when she brings up
the beheld it rosine found my mind began
to wonder those things seem to seek out
those that are in tremendous pain or
perhaps individuals with promise
certainly not the same level of promise
griffith had but it did give me a moment
for pause this rogue elf creature is in
fact rosine after all and she fell to
the bethelet which means there's reason
to believe that the person she was once
still resides somewhere deep down as she
yielded her attack once jill placed
herself in between guts and herself
making me stop to think for a second i
wonder if the person griffith is still
there and if he is is it someone that
would have compassion for anyone is
anything more important to him than his
current conquest my guess would be no
but who's to say for sure i have no idea
what's to come in the story i want to
keep this section brief as it's sort of
an aside to the main focus of this story
instead picking up on the broader
significance of certain aspects that
came to my attention while reading this
arc concerning the character of rosine
she seems to have appeared during the
eclipse in front of rickard which
creates i suppose a natural segue into
me pointing out my acknowledgement of
other apostles that have appeared in
other arcs like the snake man from
chapter one the trouble count from the
end of the black swordsman arc and of
course the apostle that killed corkus it
was the one guts obliterated in the very
first pages of book one oh and by the
way i'd like to thank the commenter that
pointed that out to us a while back we
definitely would have missed that had
you not pointed that out to us so thank
you additionally and perhaps most
importantly concerning the present story
we're exploring in this video something
happens between guts and pop that's
perhaps the most overt and explicit
example of there being a fate that's
drawing them towards each other having
had a falling out and going their
separate ways part ways through the
midpoint of this arc pox seemingly
without his knowledge is drawn back
inadvertently to the area guts is
heading the misty valley where rosine
has brought jill i still don't fully
understand what this means in the long
term but it's definitely interesting to
see how it might develop and with jill
now having been kidnapped and taken by
rosine into her land of the elves in
this misty valley guts is slaughtering
his way to rosine without her knowledge
there's a collision course after being
set so let's discuss the climax and the
ending of this arc
the lost children arc is a story about
coping with trauma jill and rosine two
young girls and in many ways are point
of view antagonist and protagonist of
the arc unlike previous arcs in this
story got to seem less like the central
character and reality more like the
opposing force of antagonism to the
events that transpire it's honestly
fascinating and yet the paradise rosine
creates for herself
turns into a flaming hellscape
[Applause]
[Music]
in this climax the action is insane the
visuals are ridiculously beautiful and
harrowing and guts really brings the
intensity and he is very much the
pressure onto the evil in this story but
in the end he reveals that he isn't the
answer that jill is looking for the
salvation she desires from the torment
of her upbringing she confides in him
and wants to escape with him anywhere
else but he reveals to her that his
battlefield isn't any better and that
she too should return to her own
in the story it brings to the forefront
of our minds sometimes you can't be
happy sometimes there are no happy
endings sometimes all we can do is
continue to struggle and fight
he disappeared into the darkness and in
the end i still didn't know who he was
just like when he appeared he took the
demons away
i was the only one left behind
i still don't really know what these
past days of fear sadness and shock were
to me
the mist cleared away
the mist that would never go away was
pushed out by the flames the clear sky
now peeks through
but it's by no means a spectacle that
makes my heart leap
like when i flew in the sky with rosine
it's
savage
only
cold
but
such a vivid sky
it's a clear sky
like the kind after a storm blows
through
i don't have wings so
i guess i'll look up at the sky and
crawl along the earth
maybe i can change something
the poetry in lost children's closing
chapters are a poignant and bittersweet
reminder that while comfort can be found
in fantasy and delusion the clear vivid
and real skies we seek so desperately in
life come at the expense of what we
thought it was we wanted sometimes your
most desperate dreams are destined to be
just that but you have a choice to exist
in the real world and appreciate what
you have when you have it or to lose
yourself like rosain in the delusions
and desires she had for the impossible
in this arc miura really does explore
themes of escapism through delusion the
story of rosine is one of tragedy and so
too is jill's a tale of tragedy with one
discernible difference jill's tragedy is
one of possibility one that contains
hope for the future and in the end if
berserk has taught me anything it's that
while things can get worse they can also
get much better and that alone is worth
struggling for both rosin and jill seek
ways to escape their realities burdened
with a feeling of not belonging having
grown up in families they don't feel a
connection with both rosin and jill see
themselves as picaf in his tale and
their respective journeys reflect his
actions in that children's story but in
slightly different ways ways that
explore the messaging of this arc in an
intensely effective fashion rosine
creates her nightmarish paradise filled
with the fake friends and guardians she
was denied as a child while jill asked
guts to take her to look for another
paradise once the action and events
subside in both cases guts is the one
who gives them their respective reality
checks firstly by killing rosine and
forcing her to see what is real and
secondly by showing jill the reality of
what she's asking for the nightmarish
demons that haunt him every single night
there is no paradise only battlefields
and by accepting reality jill ends up
seeking her own way to confront her own
life's numerous obstacles and her own
destiny the same way guts does for a
manga so rife with conflict and
grotesque acts of violence and
misconduct the berserk series has
surprised me by reliably providing some
of the most perfectly poetic moments
like guts's heart to heart with jill at
the end there is no paradise for you to
escape to what's there is just a
battlefield another friendly reminder
that even the most powerful or monstrous
among us face struggles only they can
fully appreciate and understand and that
we are all in one way or another
struggling our own way through life it
should go without saying at this point
that quintaro miura is a league into and
of his own when it comes to the
condition of his layouts and the
presentation given to these stories he's
so feverishly lavished with his deepest
considerations rosine's death is an
absolute highlight from this section and
another reminder that while he's
immensely talented at depicting some of
the most horrific tragedies one can
conjure in their mind is also able to
elicit an ethereal and otherworldly
tragic beauty also i took a slightly
different direction with this arc and i
thought the inclusion of a fairy tale in
this story was an interesting angle for
which to tackle the material and to be
clear this is the main reason why the
more bombastic aspects of the story like
the fight with guts and the bandits that
were later turned into insects or
details like rosine having already shown
off her control over bug demons in the
golden age arc didn't take the main
focus of this video and speaking of guts
and rosin the final bout between the two
of them is brutally fantastic but as you
know the element that always receives
the main focus from me is the story
storytelling over action and because we
are now out of material that has a
companion anime my editor now only has
manga panels for which to create visuals
and thus making these videos has become
a much much more time-consuming effort
and pretty much like i did last time
with the character of zod i'm saving my
thoughts on the holy iron chain knights
for the second part of the conviction
tale as i have a feeling we're gonna see
much more of them later in the story but
in closing if you haven't read berserk
yet please do so it's honestly a story
unlike any i've read this was only part
one of this arc and let me tell you i
was not prepared for what the rest of
the conviction arc had in store
[Music]
this arc contains within it not only the
best chapter i've read from berserk but
perhaps the single greatest chapter or
most impactful i've read in my life
[Music]
while lost children felt like a brief
de-wriggling of the main story the
conviction arc as a whole contains
within it not only a fascinating
continuation of the story but some harsh
truths and tough subject matter the
likes of which i've seldom seen explored
in this medium and certainly nowhere
near as tactfully executed this arc is a
special one and i want to do it justice
normally when i tackle the series on my
channel i immerse myself into the
material wholly and entirely until such
time it's finished one piece almost six
months of nothing but one piece on my
channel jojo's bizarre adventure only
jojo for months and months and the same
can be said for dragon ball and even
hunter hunter but berserk is the first
series i've done where after every video
i'm forced to take a break for almost a
full month between sessions of reading
this is for logistical reasons as we
can't feasibly make videos using only
manga week in and week out but in turn
this created for me a relationship with
this story that i honestly couldn't have
predicted a reaction that with any other
manga would have conjured a resentful
disaster having to constantly pull
myself from material i'm outwardly
enjoying like naruto and dragon ball for
the express purpose of reacquainting
myself with this very dense and
emotionally draining series it seems
like it would be a recipe for disaster
and thus was the mindset i found myself
to be in every single time i have to
tackle this berserk series and i won't
deny this i want to be honest it's a
series that over the last few months has
forced me to stay off balance as i
switch from the comparably softer and
easier to understand material to
[Music]
child murder and complicated thematic
and symbolic orchestrations from a
master of his craft it's a lot of work
but every single time i grumpily pick up
these volumes for the purposes of making
a video and yet every single time they
without exception never allow me to put
them down they are some of the best
conceived works not only of a manga but
art that i've ever been exposed to it's
like the movie 50 first dates only
instead of adam sandler berserk forces
me to fall in love with it every single
time and so i guess what i'm trying to
say is berserk is the 51st dates of
manga and on this occasion i was
confronted by an arc that reduced me to
tears and a chapter that shook my very
soul and unlike the previous berserk
reviews after finishing this arc i
decided to research a bit before i began
writing this time apparently the
conviction arc is broken up into three
separate sections lost children which i
covered last week binding chain and
finally birth ceremony the latter two
will of course receive the vast majority
of the focus in this video but through
my research i learned that quite a few
people don't like lost children which
was interesting to me but i think it's
understandable allow me to explain my
impressions of this divide and where i
think they stem from the black swordsman
arc i covered in my very first video was
unanimously seen as a decent start with
stunning visuals despite it being a
rather unremarkable start that would
eventually build up more steam towards
its conclusion similarly through my
coverage of the golden age arc i
recognized an almost global
acknowledgement of the story's
masterpiece status amongst manga from
both fans of the material to even those
that never even read berserk in their
lives however lost children was
different there was no such unanimous
agreements there were those that loved
it those that believed it was sort of
overrated and those that straight up did
not enjoy this section at all and while
i stand by my assessment of the story in
my last review that being i really
really liked it to put it simply i also
can see that i believe i know where
those sentiments of negativity are
stemming from golden age is a much more
standard format for a story with a fully
conceived narrative that follows the
life of one central character primarily
and his relationships with other key
characters as he grows into the men we
see today it's very much a coming of age
story not at all unusual because of this
we grow a fondness for this experience
and once it ends we want to see it
continue and unfortunately lost children
didn't offer an experience that many
were yearning for after golden age
despite it being an account that
followed the events of golden age and
black swordsman arcs respectively miura
decided not to tell a story that
primarily concerned itself with guts but
instead a little girl called jill gutz
plays a substantial role but certainly
not the central position instead acting
more of a supporting character in the
central plot thus resulting in lost
children feeling a little more like a
detour after golden age's epic
adventures rather than the continuation
a lot of people wanted personally i
viewed lost children as a much needed
break from the torment that was the
conclusion of the golden age arc and i
also found it to be a sound thematic
continuation of the series for sure
however i can absolutely see why this
wasn't what a lot of people wanted
conviction arc
during this portion of the story it
became clear relatively quickly that the
main storyline that took a break after
the golden age was once again picking
itself right back up during the events
of lost children we were introduced to
this impending religious force known as
the holy iron chain knights as one of
the forces on a mission pursuing and
capturing the black swordsman and boy do
they do just that despite the high death
toll of their forces a new character by
the name of lady farnese and boy do i
have a lot to say about this girl she
secures one of the few victories over
guts in the series much to my amazement
there are of course a host of caveats to
this chance encounter but it's
compelling nevertheless keeping me
guessing the entire time as to how guts
would escape this exhausting situation
and in the end the answer was he
couldn't he was too beat up and as a
quick aside one aspect of the story that
immediately caught my attention was its
cast the story goes hard in the
character department and it's all for
the best let me tell you there's the
troubled commander of the holy iron
chain knights and religious devotee lady
fernies her develop protector and
all-around lovable badass in serpico the
horrifyingly accurate depiction of all
of religion's worst qualities in father
musgus and many many more some of which
i'll touch on later for sure i loved
every single character in this arc and i
mean that without reservation i've no
idea what the consensus is with
characters like isidro or nina later on
who are designed to i think be a bit
more divisive but from an entertainment
and thematic standpoint i found them to
be pitch perfect however it's during
this time spent as a prisoner and after
escaping that i soon began to recognize
perhaps a parallel that miura was trying
to illustrate for me lady farnese is one
of the few main characters that stood
out among the holy iron chain knights
with her being the main character of
conflict for guts as well as his
eventual hostage once he escapes she's
complicated and in many ways horrible to
our main cast full of contradictions
both professionally and emotionally
physically and mentally weak yet
commander of her forces thanks to her
father espouses to the virtues of
dignity duty restraint and kindness and
yet relentlessly lashes out to others
with the smallest infraction oftentimes
with resentful or envious motivations
confidently religious but hedonistic and
confused she's one of the most
frustrating characters in the story
fundamentally flawed as a person and one
that plays a leading role receiving i
think the most development by far in
this tale and i absolutely hated her for
most of it but god damn it she's a
brilliant character now the only reason
i found it noteworthy to mention her
contributions this early in the arc was
due to the symbolic or nostalgic nature
of them she reminded me in some ways of
casca and okay okay i know what you're
thinking but hear me out for a second
for kaska griffith may as well have been
her religion she devoted her life to him
and when it came down to choosing
between him and another she saw it sort
of like a sin almost going as far as to
kill herself in fact she tried to there
are of course a number of key
differences between these characters but
given that following lady farnese's
possession which has very similar
undertones and results by the way we're
immediately thrown back into contact
with casca's storyline and due to that i
couldn't help but feel like this was an
intentional comparison being drawn on
behalf of miura oh and by the way with
this jump to casca's storyline almost
linking these two points of view we see
a
shared dream it's honestly hard to know
it's three pages and it depicts forces
that make themselves known later on in
the story upon his conclusion massive
beasts death sickness desperation and a
white shining falcon in the middle of it
all a falcon that is shown as the desire
of this portrayed world i'm not sure in
retrospective if this was an omen
predicting what's in store during this
arc or the next but lord knows almost
all of these come to fruition during
this portion of the story or its latter
half which oddly enough made me think
about the name of this arc conviction is
an interesting name for the story and
one that i didn't fully appreciate until
such time this part of the story rolled
around given the state of guts how far
gone he is and how the entire world
seems to be in some shape or form
interested in his capture i saw this
arc's title as an indication that he'll
be captured and in this story ultimately
convicted and while that does happen in
some shape or form in this series the
tale itself is more concerned with the
alternate meaning of the term conviction
which is a firmly held belief in
something and that brings me nicely to
my favorite chapter following guth's
first time returning to rickard godot
and casca in two years
cracks in the blade cracks in the blade
sits alongside campfire of dreams as
another one of the chapters that stand
out in my head is not just brilliantly
paneled but intensely profound taking
what we thought were known motivations
of the main character and turning them
completely on their head in campfire of
dreams it was his acknowledgement that
despite being among friends and there
being a home for him there he never felt
more alienated from those around him
reminding him that he needs to find his
own dream his own desires his own
convictions and within cracks in the
blade we finally get an answer to that
question posed during campfire of dreams
and with it yet another masterful
recontextualization of events from miura
just like campfire crax's most pivotal
moments center around two people sharing
insight having a heart to heart one
reflecting on lessons he learned in his
life and another about to make the same
mistake however unlike campfire cracks's
subject matter and philosophical
profundity casts a much broader net than
just within the arc it's presented and
in fact caused me to reflect on the
broader story and even certain decisions
i've made in my life it's a chapter that
works frankly as well as it does because
those that are reading it need to hear
it given most who read this manga are of
similar age to that of guts or at least
a little bit older and i can't say many
stories have had that sort of impact on
me shining a light on the selfish
decision guts made to go out into the
world to leave casket alone and to
embrace the hatred in his heart exacting
his revenge on the monsters that took
everything from him these are traits
often glorified in manga however with
berserk godot effectively calls guts a
coward that couldn't look sorrow in this
case kaska in the eye without wavering
someone who took the easy way out rather
than confront the problems and
prioritize the god the herculean figure
that guts has been made out to be due to
the feats he's enacted on those he's
hated now feeds into the narrative that
these are all acts of cowardice and it's
a brilliant way to look at this
particular problem and as a result of
that now he's beaten himself to near
death and casket has run off somewhere
presumably dead yielding massive
consequences for this arc and its
trajectory moving forward this is
exactly the sort of cause and effect i
was looking for from this story
following the golden age and it's
another example of a narrative decision
made by miura to further bolster his
claim to the title greatest mangaka to
have ever lived and i stand by that but
honestly i'm struggling to find the
words to effectively describe just how
steeped in philosophy and carefully
curated encounters the first half of
this section is taken into the context
of the current material all of the
criticisms of lost children a story i
once described as a fairy tale of sorts
echoes the criticisms goto had for guts
in the cracks in the blade chapter
claiming that he was indulging in a
fantasy instead of the reality being
there for those that he cared about one
of the many markers i think of a great
story is its ability to recontextualize
prior events and lend greater weight to
them via new material one piece does
this to great effect and i'm seeing it
right here too in berserk time and time
again let's talk about batelets and how
they've affected this story while
staying in line with the theme of this
arc bravery in the face of indulgent
fantasy in the black swordsman arc the
count exacerbated the situation he was
in when he wasn't capable of dealing
with the horrible fate that befell his
wife in the golden age griffith lost
himself in his own fantasy which in turn
made his journey that much longer
ignoring himself for the sake of one
other person that in the end he couldn't
control in lost children rosine couldn't
deal with her own personal life so she
escaped by killing her family and
created her own paradise free from the
stresses of the real world and the list
goes on however in this arc these themes
are explored more effectively through
lady farnese constantly pretending to
herself that the various horrific
occurrences haven't happened and that
she remains the pure good god-loving
girl she wants to be instead of the
cold-blooded hedonistic murderer she has
been in the past speaking of which let's
talk about father mosgas
the depiction of father musgus as the
arbiter of god's will is one of the most
horrifying depictions i've yet seen from
this manga perhaps because he's paraded
around as a function of the church and
conceived of as a force of good his
design i think goes a long way in
reaffirming this unsettled approach that
i felt with it being far more simple and
expressionless than the other more
anatomically accurate depictions of the
human condition further making him feel
more other than any human we've come
across so far in the story shifting
gears for a moment from evil to innocent
comes the character of isidro i have no
idea what the prevailing opinion is of
this character online but i honestly
loved him i thought he offered a
reminder that innocence and childishness
is still very much alive in this world
and in the middle of these horrible
events i mean like puck said this story
would be too dark if they weren't there
with some additional surprising support
in the various tense and high-stakes
action moments in a way he sort of feels
like a more standard shonen manga
protagonist but i think that coupled
with the nature of the story really had
me worried for him on more than one
occasion further building up the tension
in the scenes that he took part in i was
certain a brave kid like this wouldn't
be long for this world but every single
time his attitude and skills lifted him
out of the bad situations he found
himself in and i was relieved and hyped
because of it i also really enjoyed how
the aspects of isidro that kept him
alive and allowed him to remain in a
position of advantage or in fact his
readiness to accept reality and warp it
to suit him furthermore isidro pretty
much like guts fights against the idea
of fate or what is established he wants
to be the best version of himself and
sees guts as someone to aspire to be
like i honestly think he's pretty
awesome and i'm delighted that moving
forward we'll get to see more of him so
look okay at this point koska's alive
which is great but she's in the heart of
one of the worst situations in midland
and the center of what will be a dark
event unlike anything we've yet seen in
the story save for perhaps the eclipse
rest in peace everyone so let's see how
this one pans out nina orgies and the
cults peggy 18.
some of the imagery in this is
frightening and perhaps not for the
reasons you might be thinking when i was
in school history was my favorite
subject i always treated the lessons
like details stories of the past and one
of the topics that stunned me the most
was the black death a massive plague
that wiped out over half of europe which
to be honest is the clear inspiration
for this plague right here in midland
massive amounts of refugees living on
top of each other terrible living
conditions horrible hygiene widespread
poverty and hunger the imagery berserk
depicts routinely demonstrates some of
the absolute worst in humanity and i
think it's a wonderful means of creating
those heroic and triumphant moments we
remember in this series too which for
one reason or another leads us to this
hedonistic cultist orgy never thought
i'd say that oh kinky
with the character of nina and her boy
toy to be clear i'd hate nina if not for
the fact that she's this way by design
i'm not supposed to like her what i do
find interesting about her though is
similar to lady fairness she has an
internal struggle coming to terms with
who she is and ought to be ethically and
that struggle is interesting given the
various strains this story puts her
through hashtag
she also introduces us to these cultists
which let's be perfectly honest creeped
me the [ __ ] out cultists that ironically
or unironically sought a similar
escapism to that of their religion
believing counterparts and because of
this they see koska as their new idol
after witnessing what happens when her
brand starts to bleed however this did
get me thinking because it seems like
contrary to guts to some degree the
demonic presences protect kaska rather
than attack her and well long story
short because of this most humans are
turned into zombies and mr goatman is
turned into an actual demonic entity the
likes of which will haunt my nightmares
forever alright but look i know what
you're thinking i glanced over something
speaking on the poetry and parallels of
these two opposing ideals colliding we
physically see them collide in the cave
as the holy iron chain knights arrive
and begin fighting these transformed
heretics it's total chaos everyone is
here puck flies as fast as he can to get
guts isidro snipes zombies with
unlimited rock ammo like the absolute
legend he is and kaska is
more vulnerable now than she ever has
been in the middle of absolute chaos and
destruction where the worst of the worst
both human and demon battle each other
the last hurt and fragile caska is all
alone outnumbered by the hordes around
her and honestly the way miora keeps
distancing both guts and casca is
frustrating but at this point it's just
overwhelming it's terrifying but in the
middle of absolute despair a faint but
glimmering light soars through the
battlefield seizing my attention
momentarily suddenly a familiar
silhouette cloaked in black flies across
the page both portrayed at the beginning
as almost part of the background and
slowly thanks to some expert paneling
they shift to being the focus of the
fight and at the height of the drama a
surging black whirlwind breaks through
the tension stopping time in its tracks
for both sides in confrontation and in
an incredible panel we finally see them
guts and casca reunited the background
is neither chaotic nor war torn just
white and the traces of what's happened
outside of one of the most intimate
panels between two misfortunate souls
separated from the rest of the conflict
separated from the rest of the world
those who struggle against this terrible
fate are together
once again naturally and regrettably
this couldn't last and as kaska is soon
apprehended and taken away to further
destruction much to guts's anger i
couldn't help but remark what a scene
the panel where they reunite is enough
to make you cry miura manages to
encapsulate all of the hurt relief and
struggle on godzi's single expression
contained on this one panel it's a
spectacular moment
oh
yes
oh my god this panel is so kino this is
more kino than anything serpico vs guts
the attempted escape from the chaos was
compelling and tense however this was
one of the smartest ambushes i've ever
seen committed to the pages of a manga
i'll keep it brief but this is certainly
like one of the best fights i've enjoyed
in the series applying knowledge we're
already familiar with the dutiful
protector of lady fernies combined with
precise placement for the battle
orchestrates one of the most respectable
one-on-one battles a character of his
standing has ever attempted against guts
and in doing so has immediately
catapulted him into the ranks of some of
my favorite humans from this series
knowing exactly where guts's weak points
are and where his own shortcomings lay
placing himself on a narrow ledge
obstructing gutz's dominant hand and
preventing him from drawing his sword
are among just a few of the strategies
implemented in this altercation and the
best thing about this character is that
he doesn't take himself too seriously
he's often depicted in a much more
humorous manner than i've come to expect
from this series as antagonists and i'm
honestly a big fan and with him
providing the delay the holy iron chain
knights needed to whisk kaska away it's
the perfect recipe to bring all the main
players together for one final showdown
saving koska going into the endgame of
this raid i was left in a complete tizzy
i honestly couldn't predict what was
going to happen i just knew that i had
to keep reading i'm just so unbelievably
invested in these characters and what
little can be salvaged of guts and
casca's relationship that i honestly
felt like the worst was on the horizon
for them miura had already demonstrated
his ability to drag these characters
down to depths i never before
anticipated and so he had me primed
expecting the very same this time around
too so much has gone wrong for guts in
this series he's lost almost everything
and casca could be i think perhaps the
final nail in the coffin for him which i
think went a very long way towards
cultivating that love i have for
isidro's character kaska is on the
stakes ready to be burned alive courtesy
of father moscow's hate that guy guts is
nowhere to be seen and otherwise trying
and failing to get there on time and
just as i was resigned to yet another
person in god's life being taken away
from him for reasons he would no doubt
blame himself for isidro drops from the
heavens and hoists her up into the air
when this happened i literally ran
straight to my fiance and said you see
that kid he's awesome to which she said
mark it's 6 a.m i'm trying to sleep we
have a great relationship this climax
honestly has it all and miura doesn't
let us down in the artistic department
either not one bit depicting father
moscow's as an angelic figure of
divinity there to protect the refugees
only made me fall in love with this
character more than i already have and
what's more was that the brilliant touch
miura gave to his character once he
strips himself down to nothing but pure
plates and muscle his primary attack is
a bludgeoning barrage of blunt strikes
there to represent a heretic stoning
he's the judge jury and executioner
amira has done everything to create a
final battle between himself and guts to
rival many of the battles we've seen in
the past it's brilliant honestly i
mentioned before how farnis denies the
ugly reality of the world she lives in
by doing nothing and constantly saying
to herself that everything is still the
same her entire identity and sanity is
built upon her religion by experiencing
the true force of the world in its most
terrifying form to the most
heartbreaking forms by moscow's turning
into one of those semi-apostles she
finally finds something real in all of
this guts standing alone never breaking
and always fighting back against this
chaotic reality check even in her
confusion when she almost drops her
torch and begins praying to her already
proven non-existent faith lying to
herself for the last time it's guts much
like he did with jill in the previous
arc who helps her find the courage to
fight back and take action by not
depending and waiting for things to
magically resolve by themselves but
instead through her own power farnese
picks up her torch and for the first
time she struggles against this cruel
reality and she decides to follow guts
and seek the answers to all of her
questions by looking at the real world
without clinging to false hopes or idols
followed by her loyal servant serpico
similar to isidro i honestly cannot wait
to see where this gang goes together
with guts in the future and it's not
just this the real story of this arc has
been guts trying everything in his power
to right the wrongs he's made and
reconnect with kaska to find her and to
protect her in her current state and at
numerous instances whether that be the
refugee camp the cultist gathering and
the raid of the castle there's always
been something to prevent him from
protecting her stopping him from staying
by the side of the one person he loves
more than anyone there's been a heavy
emphasis on the themes of fate and
causality through this story which in
some ways sort of conflict with each
other and now that the armies are
marching griffith is flying away on his
big buff zod boy and guts is riding off
into the dawn with casca i have no
friggin idea where this story is going
to take me and the best part is i'm only
halfway through this series what does
get me excited though is that isidro
lady farnese and serpico are following
closely behind guts and casca and in a
way this sort of makes me feel like
they're building towards their very own
brand of the hawk 2.0 right now and i
love all the characters present for it i
really hope the falcon of the millennium
empire arc will be as good as conviction
has been but there's only one way to
find out guys by diving straight into
the next and final completed arc from
kentaro miura's berserk the falcon of
the millennium empire
[Music]
uh
[Music]
one thing i can say about berserk
categorically is that it is dense as all
hell when it comes to its plot themes
and character writing and not
necessarily in that order either for
that reason i wasn't able to cover
everything i wanted to in the last
episode where i covered the conviction
arc's ending and so thankfully because
this arc is much less complex we have
some extra time to quickly give my
impressions on what happened with all
that craziness and while i really want
to get into how this arc kicks off like
seriously what happened took me so off
guard i nearly fell back into my chair i
want to talk about mr eggman
i'm going to try to be honest here i'm
not sure i fully grasped what happened
with regards to this weird guy following
everyone and lurking in the shadows
throughout a portion of that arc with
that said something about his design
mixed with his uncharacteristic lack of
involvement with the story made me feel
i don't know uneasy in ways this story
hasn't managed to achieve thus far and
i've seen some stuff in this story upon
closer inspection the conviction act
generally speaking is all about what
people desire the most and the
conviction that it takes for them to
achieve those ends ironically or
fittingly while the entire world is
begging for salvation in the conviction
arc the eggman who comes from the worst
most rotten places of society someone
who doesn't even really consider himself
a person is the one that works as a
vessel for this quote salvation granting
an answer to those desires by bringing
the hawk of light into the mortal world
griffith is back and seems to be totally
fine again in his mortal form which is
oh my i don't even know if i can process
that right now the eggman as someone who
watched over albion and its people first
as a spectator and later as some sort of
participant transforming mozgus and his
torturers into semi-apostles is easy to
miss at first but how this tiny thing
became the center of the story still
without anybody noticing and achieving
his own goals by literally changing the
world forever is poetic and sort of
prophetic in a sense when you think
about this arc's title the furthermore
and we're getting there the cursed child
of casca and guts appeared many times
during the story seemingly to protect
casca but in the end runs out of gas or
dies either way he is absorbed by the
eggman so they both don't die alone
which is so fittingly berserk i don't
know why i didn't see that coming is
this the end of this character
i'm not so sure i don't think miura
would make the cursed child show up just
to help out the main character and then
vanish but only time will tell i guess
by the end of the conviction arc itself
the predictions of skull knight are once
again challenged by guts and once again
while everything happens according to
what he says one thing remains different
guts and casca are reunited and it's
thanks to all the people guts knew and
all the people that decided to follow
him throughout this story interestingly
there are some similarities between
events from the past that we can notice
here too we have another eclipse
griffith is reborn into another divine
being guts and casca are saved and even
some parallels i mentioned before
between farnese and casca also exist and
if we want to get really crazy there
could be some inversions that play here
too the hawks died during the eclipse
and golden ages climax while guts's new
friends all survive in conviction and
some of them even decide to follow his
tracks perhaps this is an indication
that guts is slowly edging his way to an
outcome that's imminently desirable
rather than an outright horror show or a
compromise like this conviction climax
was but okay to round out my analysis of
the conviction arc's conclusion before i
move on to something else i think i
should share my favorite part of this
story which was gutz's choosing of
protection for casca over vengeance
towards griffith having once been a man
destroying himself on this endless
violent crusade for revenge thanks to
the lessons he's learned in this story
chose the less indulgent and selfish
option guts the protector of kaska and
interestingly the panel structure here
seems to be a homage to one of miora's
favorite mangas devil just a fun fact
that i thought i'd include with that
said griffith's rebirth is astonishing
the circumstances surrounding the
kingdom with the kushan army in stride
is pretty suspenseful the people of
midland full of fear and hope is
appropriate and guts and casca fighting
for their lives and griffith flying over
some of the most incredible landscapes
i've ever seen in manga kicks off this
next arc
falcon of the millennium empire as i
noted towards the beginning of the last
section one of the arc's strong points
is i think its ability to take complex
emotional stakes and present them in a
format that's honestly quite easy to
follow on a surface level this will help
in my conciseness when writing this
review and so instead of going through
things one at a time in a boring fashion
considering that this arc thus far is
split up into two plot lines guts and
griffiths respectively i thought the
best way to tackle this video is by
exploring my impressions on each of
these plot lines individually that is
after what happens in the very first
scene of this arc when guts arrived with
casket in tow to their small base of
operations and i saw that griffith was
waiting for them i think i had what
could only be described as a mild
aneurysm after having come to terms with
choosing to protect casca after giving
up what was the perfect opportunity to
take him out at the climax of the prior
arc seeing him here like this was one of
the most stunning instances i've
experienced in the story there's been a
running trend since the very beginning
of this manga with it framing a number
of instances and moments highlighting
that griffith is out of reach of guts
sometimes metaphorically and sometimes
quite literally however there have been
instances where he's surprised even
griffith with his very existence flying
in the face of what should have happened
to him by now he should have died guts's
sheer determination to struggle onward
towards his goal is the savage heartbeat
of this story however in this scene
kicking things off while griffith
appears to be the same person he knew
back then as he has been in the case of
every prayer tale he is still
unreachable
god the immortal stands before guts as
the formidable obstacle he is with a new
conviction his sword once lost in the
boredom of thousands of battles finds a
new purpose to protect his overlord
griffith against the giant dragon slayer
of guts once more the two rivals clash
while watching this take place it felt
almost as if time was standing still
while the action is naturally as good as
one might expect from miura with some
outstanding illustrations on display it
was griffith's short conversation with
guts that retook the reigns of this
scene for me this is the first time
these two have been in communication
with each other in such a long period of
time and for griffith to effectively
espouse the same rhetoric and vibe as
when he was in the golden age arc is
both nostalgic and haunting at the same
time with the context of what's happened
since those simpler times and it's in
this short but illuminated conversation
we noticed something a little different
about guts instead of the man who had a
clear conviction for revenge or
protection he seems to be stuck in a
sort of limbo unable to fully and
completely dedicate himself to one goal
more on that in just a bit there was one
instance that i found quite surprising
during this scene and that was
griffith's sudden protection of kaska
there's the obvious contrast being made
here with guts in that griffith seems to
be single-minded in his goals and
therefore without hesitation can act in
this case protecting casca however this
conflicts quite violently i think with
the heinous acts he's perpetrated in the
past to both guts and specifically casca
he's perfectly willing to sacrifice any
number of people if it means him
reaching his goal of ruling over a
kingdom but this stands in direct
contrast with that i'm not sure what to
make of it but perhaps it's a mind game
the very last time gut saw griffith in
this state and appearance he had left
griffith outmatched and defeated on his
knees as he walked off in the snow snow
in this series carries with it a
tremendous amount of symbolism i've
noticed it can be interpreted as the
cleaning of the old slate and fresh
start and it can be emblematic of
isolation and emptiness when godz
defeated griffith back during the golden
age arc he inadvertently shook the
status quo in everyone's eyes and
griffith knew that which in addition to
his caring for guts was part of the
reason why he reacted like he did
however this scene's conclusion almost
acts as griffith's revenge for that
moment as he leaves guts alone in the
snow after a crushing battle with his
minion zod with him holding all the
cards and through kaska reminding him of
what he did to her but that's just my
take
following this scene the two main
characters guts and griffith fracture
into two separate storylines while they
naturally reconnect at a later point i
will be diving into gutz's portion of
the story first as it's by far what i
have the most to talk about and by
extension what i found the most
entertaining and interesting
guts picking up the pieces following
this climactic battle a new goal or
destination becomes apparent kaska
cannot take care of herself and this
safe haven they once knew has been
destroyed because of gotz's battle with
zod perhaps again this could be symbolic
that guts can't have it both ways he can
protect kaska while also fighting zod
and by proxy griffith this speaks to the
conflict in guts's mind which this arc
deals with predominantly as he travels
to pock's home the land of the elves and
this is where the character running for
guts gets extremely interesting on these
travels guts realizes how difficult it
is fighting the demons of the night that
attack while also having to consider
casca's protection everything was easier
when he didn't need to hold back when he
could indulge in that more animalistic
side of himself that side that he knew
could struggle and survive
however he can't do that now he has to
fight 10 times harder in order to stay
alive and to protect kaska and can't
afford to be a savage sword seeking
blood any longer now he instead has to
learn to be a shield and a sword the
pressure of which ends up breaking him a
sentiment echoed through quotes like
sword feels heavier than ever or casca
is a shell of the person she once was is
there any trace of the old casket inside
of her or even he wanted to rescue her
and now he did now what he reached the
goal but how can he keep his promise to
her and to himself of never abandoning
her all of these quotes speak to the
frustration the conflict and ultimately
the mindset of guts that wants to
believe casca is worth it but just like
in every difficult challenge there's
always that side that tries to
rationalize away out of that tough
responsibility particularly when the
stakes are as high as they are for guts
and this is where miora decided to
explore something really interesting
within guts's character since the
beginning of the story there has always
been a more primal or beast-like persona
that guts wooden body in order to
successfully survive his day-to-day
existence what i once thought was an
artistic choice depicting guts as this
beast of the darkness has become a very
tangible and real plot element since
lost children we've been aware of the
beast in black and following a difficult
series of frustrations surrounding casca
struggling to protect her and even
questioning whether or not he should any
longer she goes
missing after having promised himself
that he would never lose her again in
the adrenaline fear and frustration guts
snaps the beast once again takes over
and in the process
hurts kaska scars kaska the person he
loves the most in a fashion eerily
reminiscent of what griffith committed
he became a monster and if we ignore the
obvious and awful imagery for a second
there's a phenomenal piece of
storytelling taking place here through
this character that calls all the way
back to the very beginning of his life
and that character being called back to
is
gambino when we were first introduced to
gambino way back at the very beginning
of the golden age arc we were presented
with this rough around the edges tough
soldier type that was good at what he
was a soldier a fighter a killer if he
wasn't good at being that then he would
have likely died long before he could
even have been any sort of father figure
good or bad to guts when he was younger
however once he lost the ability to
fight he started to more obviously and
overtly lash out in terrible ways which
ultimately led to his downfall he
couldn't be a good father a good
nurturer or a good carer perhaps in part
because all of his life he had to do the
opposite to survive to look out only for
himself this obviously isn't to excuse
anything he did in the story but it
speaks to perhaps his mindset and
psychology when in those moments this
facet of his being being perhaps so
useful in keeping him alive that it
became who he was and when he was
stripped of his ability to utilize that
strength he broke similarly guts has
lived a life as of late where he's been
forced to fight for his life against
odds he's been told are insurmountable
with death waiting around every single
corner in order to survive this miura
has shown us how animalistic and
beast-like he becomes once fighting off
hordes of monsters and demons defying
what he was told was impossible it
served him as a useful function and as
such has pushed him in a direction of
being someone that wants to be alone and
wants to be someone that relishes in
crushing the weak and taking what he can
for himself which brings us to this
moment where he makes the decision to
not indulge in those heinous acts any
longer and instead do what's difficult
he decided to care to care for and above
all else protect casca and along the way
he quickly discovers how difficult it is
to do that how difficult it is to remain
compassionate and human in those dire
circumstances and how easy it might be
during those more difficult moments to
allow oneself to be lost to those darker
impulses in other words in real time we
are seeing what it might have been like
for someone not as strong as guts to go
through something like this in gambino
what it might have been like for a
prisoner of war who can't let the battle
go and following this guts feels
horrific and rightfully so the very same
trauma got experienced and in many ways
still is experiencing after what gambino
did to him was what he passed on to
kaska what he scarred casca with the
fear of being touched or more
specifically in this instance the fear
of guts himself how can they keep going
well euro gave us an answer almost
immediately guts
needs help
farnese and serpico since their
introduction to this story halfway
through the conviction arc after lost
children the dynamic of serpico and lady
farnese has been an enjoyable one and
perhaps that's putting it a little too
lightly serpico from the outset is very
easy to respect and cheer for even when
he decided to take on the main character
guts on the side of a cliff during the
conviction arc i still found myself
cheering his innovative and
opportunistic efforts in taking down
guts to help his lady farnese however
with her on the other hand having been
introduced as a religious extremist with
strong swaths of sadism right beneath
her unassuming and innocent facade lady
farnese has been a character i never
thought i would get the chance to
actually explore in greater detail
let alone appreciate berserk is in one
way or another quite interested in
demonstrating how awful people can be
while also possessing the courage to
explore the reasons as to why that might
be the case farnese is shown to be a
hateful entitled scornful bigot that
relishes in the literal burning of
innocent people and yet through the
flashbacks we receive either through
serpico and herself we discover that her
upbringing was far from normal or secure
in some senses through the eyes of
serpico himself surprise journey and
history is as you might expect he's a
determined attentive and appreciative
individual with unwavering loyalty to
those he feels a connection with having
come from the slums and from a mother
that struggled to cling to reality it
was farnese's request to take him in
that ultimately plucked him from a life
of scrounging to a life by her side
where serpico ended up witnessing some
of the unsavory aspects of her character
and many of her struggles first hand and
this is where there might be a parallel
to point out with regards lady fairness
and casca casca and farnese are sort of
a package deal in this arcuacy all the
while guts does what guts does best hack
and slash farnese guards casca with her
life something she never would have done
when we first encountered her in other
words she seems to be on a path to
redemption it's made clear early in this
act that farnese carries with her in
admiration and curiosity for guts and
what he's managed to show her since
meeting him her entire worldview has not
only been challenged but successfully
shattered compare this to cask's
experience with griffith who changed her
worldview and following that held her
devotion kaska was lost in a fantasy and
idealistic cocoon-like vision of what
griffith really was fairness on the
other hand by following gods has managed
to actually better herself she's gotten
stronger both mentally and physically
and in addition to that surprica has
even remarked that she is becoming more
compassionate she's starting to feel
more human in other words guts was a
positive influence on her life while
griffith was a negative one on casca's
and fittingly farnese becomes casca's
security blanket in this section
isidro there isn't a lot to discuss here
at least not in comparison to guts casca
farnis or even serpaco but i am
thoroughly enjoying what isidro
contributes to the story in more than
one way on a surface level there's
something to appreciate with his growing
rapport alongside puck their comedy
helps to alleviate the dire or intense
scenes a little bit and by doing so
helps to enhance those more serious
moments by creating a wonderful contrast
in tone a similar technique has been
used not only in comics but also live
action films for decades for reference
think about how effective robin williams
was at shifting from humor to more
dramatic tones in the blink of an eye
they often go hand in hand i mentioned
before that i appreciated the
commonalities that existed between a
sidro and a more traditional shonen
protagonist also which shine through
magnificently within this portion of the
story while he is by no means the focus
the minor subplot or character arc he's
undergoing in this arc is quite
cathartic he wants to be the best of
what he's trying to do and when he
doesn't measure up to the other talents
of other warriors in the party like guts
or serpico you can visibly see the
disappointment in himself descend across
his face and while this aspect of him is
explored in more detail with guts
encouraging him to use his strengths and
to follow what feels right to him the
real struggles in his development are
made with the introduction of a brand
new character and addition to the party
the little witch shirukei shirake and
the astral world magic has joined the
party ladies and gentlemen now that
might sound like a tongue-in-cheek
comment but in reality it's true i don't
want to spend a ton of time speculating
on the circumstances surrounding the
astral world and what the ramifications
of that might be because i'm smart
enough to understand that i can't fully
comprehend the scope of what this offers
the story in the future however i will
speak to what i think of the character
shiroke the little witch in training is
an interesting addition to the story
from a conceptual and utilitarian
standpoint with regards to the narrative
she offers a bunch to the party that
they otherwise cannot do and she acts as
a manifestation of magic in this world
in a big and bombastic way and quite
auspiciously she offers an interesting
contrast to isidro's character too
whereas cidro acts as a naive blowhard
surprised when he can't live up to his
own expectations cheetah case seems to
be the exact opposite of that she's had
the necessary training the backing of
her mentor and teacher but lacks the
belief in herself and her abilities in
many ways to fully make use of them this
is specifically interesting as a
citroe's dynamic with her fuels his own
insecurities acting at first towards her
as one of the boys in this team he
slowly realizes that she is far more
capable than he is feeling this feeling
of inadequacy that he has and that's not
even to make mention of the magic on
display here since griffith did the
whole ooga booga and became the demon of
the night and then the hawk of light
once again in his reincarnation it's no
exaggeration to state that in the
immortal words of will smith this world
has been flip turned upside down demons
are everywhere and now magical creatures
roam the land thanks to the astral world
intersecting with the reality guts
understands interestingly she decay all
the while she has to contend with her
own uncertainty i adore what she means
for the story and how she impacts the
actions of the rest of the party that
isn't even to make mention of the
massive water bending and darkness
entity she manages to entangle herself
within which in and of itself is
inherently interesting as a power set
from a visual standpoint but also
because of the drawback to using such a
massive amount of magic at numerous
times we see her unable to disconnect
and almost lose herself in these moments
of entanglement and it's just
fascinating watching as she picks and
chooses when to make use of these
abilities she has particularly
interesting in the context of her being
this fledgling witch tasked with holding
everyone else's hand through this
experience it's wonderfully handled like
she gives the team their own enchanted
items serpico becomes a feather dusting
airbender isidro becomes a pyromaniac
and guts gets the big black armor
otherwise known as the berserker armor
i touched on this aspect of gutz's
character in the early portion of this
video and cited his more animalistic
side coming out manifesting in a very
physical and real way it was horrific
and well this berserker armor is sort of
the natural extension on that idea with
even more trade-offs beyond the clear
and obvious psychological ones on both
himself and those he inflicts pain upon
the berserker armor as i understand it
is brilliant for all the same mechanical
reasons as the kaioken is in dragon ball
z there's a tremendous entertainment and
suspense factor attached to it while it
amplifies the wearer's strength and
resilience the damage the body is forced
to absorb is compounded by the armor's
ability to keep the wearer going this
aspect of the armor in addition to the
primal animalistic and frankly demonic
state guts is now tapping into creates
the perfect storm for this armor to work
its magic and work its magic it most
certainly does once griffith's forces
ambushed the team with one of the main
warriors in those forces grunbelled
looking to take on guts one on one and
with the berserker armor it becomes
clear that grunbelt despite wanting a
real fight must assume his real form in
order to survive this encounter with
this new power of guts and his real form
is oh it's spectacular the dude is a
giant crystal dragon the page spread
revealing his true form was absolutely
gorgeous it's certainly up there with
some of the most impactful page turns
for me in this series and i love how his
white regal and bright facade clashes
and contrasts starkly with the black
savage and dark appearance of guts and
his newly acquired armor the fight is
great but ultimately serves the
narrative function of communicating how
his new berserker armor works and long
story short it's sick and it works great
the beach
guts and his party at the beach is a
beautiful chapter with miura at his best
in terms of character writing shidukei
and guts begin to formulate the
foundations of a closer relationship
ultimately focusing on the issues that
both he guts and shi shiroke have to
contend with moving forward with both of
them carrying a tremendous amount of
weight on their shoulders respectively
both dealing with difficult decisions
they need to make shitake needing to
follow her late teachers lessons in
finding a way to believe in what guts
can do despite her head telling her that
it's impossible which is sort of ironic
because she deals specifically in magic
which in and of itself is sort of beyond
belief and then we have guts on the
other hand staring at what he could be
pursuing a quiet and normal life for
casca but this is berserk and a tranquil
quiet moment can't last too long cutting
this warm moment short skull line
appears again to tease us once more with
guts's destiny and in doing so addresses
something important helping us
understand that in order to deal with
griffith one has to challenge the
world's rules this speaks to shitake's
issue somewhat but i wonder if this
armor gutz has recently acquired
transcends his body to something more
than human or perhaps he could be
speaking to his demonic state only time
will tell i suppose but one thing that
has struck me from this arc has been
when skull knight remarks on some
potential good news guts received about
caska the elf king they are heading
towards seems to have the ability to
restore kaska to who she was once before
this is insanely great news for guts
however this is berserk skull knight
speculates as to whether or not casket
will wish for the same thing guts
desires and it's a frightening sentiment
and possibility for guts to have to
contend with however the more i think
about it the more i can make sense of
that statement it's been remarked upon
numerous times that this casket is
distinctly different to the casket we
all know and love from before in golden
age and so in theory making this wish
for her in a sense would be like asking
to be killed and born anew this current
casket would need to make the wish to
reset and restore the previous casket
with different memories an entirely
different person suddenly this fairy
tale-like mechanic is dealing with some
really complex philosophical questions
about identity and existence the final
thing i want to acknowledge about
gutsu's squad before i move on to
griffith is this little kid the casket
picks up at the beach there's something
weird about this kid something mystical
or i don't know something they sort of
look like mokuba from yu-gi-oh and with
this thematic tie to kaska i can only
imagine how this little one would play a
role in how his story unfolds moving
forward
griffith and speaking of unfolding
stories it's finally time to properly
meet the invaders to midland and by
association griffith to this portion of
the story now seeing as i will only be
reviewing the first half of this arc
griffith's portion of the story is
actually significantly smaller than the
team of guts's so let's explore what i
can concerning his return and expansion
into midland much the same as the golden
age arc griffith is depicted as this
ethereal and angelic presence descending
onto the filthy commoners groveling in
fear since the beginning of the story
the kushan empire has never been a focus
but boy does it play a leading role as
the main obstacle to griffith and his
new crew the new band of the hawk is
unveiled piece by piece to us with each
subsequent area griffith conquers and
liberates coming from the cushing empire
and with it bringing a new addition to
his crew there's this little girl called
sonja that has this strange almost
psychic ability and similar to kaska she
has become infatuated or obsessed in a
sense with griffith for it was his
presence she believes that granted her
that power other characters joined the
ranks early on both human and i guess
dragon alike as we saw earlier however
we don't really come to fully comprehend
the full scope of griffith's new army
until we come to know the character of
mew a newly liberated leader that soon
gets befriended by sonja and in her
efforts to introduce him to griffith
personally she walks him past
increasingly creepier and creepier
followers until he reaches a literal
demonic entities lurking in the dead of
night griffith is dealing with a whole
new level of force when it comes to his
army granting us perhaps a glimpse of
the sort of kingdom griffith expects to
rule over of all the conquests and
captures in these chapters for griffith
and the new band of the hawk by far my
favorite scene comes in the form of
griffith's advancement and attack on the
cushion emperor ganeshka this fellow is
an apostle yes however he is distinctly
different to all the others we've seen
so far as he refuses to vow himself to
any one allegiance beyond his own not
even the godhead by their very nature
apostles normally will follow the orders
of the god hand yet this character wants
to transcend them he says i'll reign
over this unclean world as a demon king
and rebel against
god he wants to become a higher power
which makes him the perfect enemy to
griffith in this part of the story
however i would be lying if i said that
this character alone is the reason this
scene is my favorite because he's not
he's not even remotely my favorite
aspect of it
this is there's a tremendous amount of
history between griffith and princess
charlotte we know what griffith wants we
know what he's done in the past to her
we know what he's become we understand
charlotte's desire to be with him again
and we can all see where this whole
scene is going what was once depicted as
a horror show when griffith last climbed
through her window is presented in this
instance like a fantastic joyous
storybook ending to a romance that
spanned generations the paneling here is
spectacular and the look on charlotte's
face says it all carried forth by a
one-horned beast across the sparkling
night sky atop her bed griffith her
dazzling prince charming has come to her
rescue where this will go
i perish the thought which finally
brings us full circle to the unexpected
reunion of the two main parties gotz's
team and griffith's band and strangely
there's no conflict upon first encounter
griffith doesn't see guts again but
instead shirakei encounters sonja the
girl that can read minds becoming fast
friends in the process sonia offers [ __ ]
okay to come with them but ultimately
shoot okay declines funnily enough
during this two isidro meets a knight as
he fights with the pirate port this
knight is obviously azan after taking
the blame for superconfirence's leaving
of the holy chain knights i've elected
to henceforth call him totally not azan
the first portion of this section
largely deals with lady farney's desire
to help her friends solve a rather
persistent issue the acquisition of a
ship with which to sail to their desired
destination all the while superco has
his own issues he needs to deal with but
i'll get to him in just a second with
farni's throughout this journey she's
transformed from a self-obsessed
confused and delusional girl full of
hatred and sadistic tendencies to a
strong young woman slowly coming to
terms with reality beyond the scope of
many all the while showing a warmth
within her that's unmatched by many if
not all of the party and it's a
testament to her character that this
warmth and care she shows towards kaska
and the desire she gets to broaden her
horizons with magic gets shelved or put
on the back burner indefinitely for the
express purposes of helping her friends
acquire a ship even if that means them
moving on with their journey without her
it's an interesting plot point in its
own right introducing us to the broader
family and the struggle for power and
respect that dwells there but as i
mentioned it too serves and executes
brilliantly the function of highlighting
just how far lady fernies has come as a
human being in this story furthermore as
a quick aside i really like the role
magic as a concept is playing in this
tale it represents the change that's
taking place both figuratively and
literally inside of her opening herself
up to the possibilities that she might
be able to change and for her seeing the
results of magic would act as somewhat
of a validation for that change however
now she seems to have lost her nerve
opting to be of use in the only way she
sees herself to be of use to others as a
pawn providing a ship to her friends
however in making that decision
ironically and appropriately she
unconsciously demonstrates that exact
change she wishes to see within herself
by making that very choice leveraging
her status as an aristocrat marrying
herself off and while guts and co in
quite a cute and familial fashion move
to confront her about this to rescue her
from herself the monsters they once saw
the shores during the last section start
to emerge all the while another obstacle
makes himself known before standing in
their way
ding ding ding it's serpaco vs guts
round two while guts is all muscle and
tenacity surprico is all strategy and
tactics and fittingly this acts as a
great lesson for isidro as he watches
the conflict once upon a time he was
taught the value of understanding one's
shortcomings as a fighter in a fight and
circo is the physical manifestation of
that very idea to its extreme but
ignoring yesidra for a second the story
of this fight is a profound one that's
beautiful in its depth of character
introspection conflict fights and
contests between two individuals in
manga and indeed's story are great
because of the contrast and indeed
information the readers or viewers can
glean from that contrast you need look
no further than goku and vegeta in
dragon ball or more abstractly luffy
versus the world government in one piece
when two forces clash they highlight
their respective differences in the
prior two examples many of the
encounters these contests share serve to
highlight the struggle between good
versus evil however with regards serpico
and guts in this instance the contrast
and conflict doesn't serve to highlight
the struggle of good versus evil
necessarily but instead something far
more nuanced and fundamental to each
respective character that speaks to the
soul of their respective designs in
berserk guts represent struggle and
tenacity in the face of overwhelming
terror and destruction serpaco on the
other hand as he puts it adapts to his
circumstances to fill a role that is
presented to him to accept what is
before him even if it is unreasonable
and so unbeknownst to me as this fight
unraveled it revealed itself to be a
classic clash of ideologies not good
versus evil necessarily again but more
so an irresistible force guts versus the
immovable object of serpico however only
one here seems to be struggling with
something and it isn't guts addressing
gods as someone he serpico who once
turned a blind eye to everything can now
not simply ignore and as a result fears
what might happen if he discovers more
about himself and continues to change in
this party what that change might
manifest as within him and so
interestingly while lady fernie's story
is all about her desire for something
more to change herself serpico's story
seems to be more about his desire to
remain the same to not change into
someone who can't turn a blind eye like
he used to he doesn't trust guts
entirely and that scares him the fight
itself ends about as fast as it begins
however and while there were some
tremendous ideas on display with some
wonderful introspection from serpico
guts emerges the victor and the panels
both leading up to and during this fight
were spectacular there's such a
wonderful sense of motion with each
panel beautifully and perfectly
connecting the threads of serpico's
thoughts to the motions of his sword
more so perhaps than any other fight in
this series i really felt the rhythm of
this one like a dance the fight worked
with the story being told each more
emphatic and effective because of each
other following this event gut serpico
and the team storm the banquet hall lady
fernies and our family are residing
within just in the nick of time too to
make the save and perhaps this is a
coincidence but i may have noticed that
there were some similarities to how
farnese was saved by serpico when
compared to gutz's saves with casca way
back when instead of a flash of black
there was a flash of white before
serpico appears by farnese's side
protecting her from harm however unlike
the previous encounters where farnese
felt like a burden while guts was
hacking tiger monsters in tremendous
fashion into bits and serpico went to
take down the source of the trouble in
front of her family and indeed her
companions farnese takes down a tiger
using a magical item proving to herself
that she is capable of the sort of
change she desires to see in herself and
as a short plot beat i really like this
something i did neglect to mention the
prior video was a certain encounter guts
has with a particular member of a
significant group you might have heard
of him the god hand as we saw in the
conviction arc conrad one of the god
hand members was responsible for the
plague in midland all the while slan the
girly god hand member was responsible
for the orgy club nina was part of and
during the events of this arc's first
half you may have noticed that we met
with her again manifesting herself via
troll intestines tempting guts to use
his battlelit and become an apostle the
god hands are always present in this
story and for a reason that's more than
likely going to be clear in the not so
distant future everything they've done
so far even putting everything in place
for griffith's incarnation ceremony
seems to be connected to griffith
himself but slan's presence here not
only serves to make this obvious but
also to introduce us to something even
more terrifying
enter
the sword of actuation skull knight
sword made of balelits otherwise known
as the most metal concept for a weapon
in the entire series this is a weapon
that's been created by skull knight that
has been specifically crafted to kill in
humans the concept of this sword is
absolutely insane and abundantly clear
why skull knight is the main enemy of
the godhand members it can basically cut
through reality reaching even the
deepest layers of the astral world you
might remember the abyss that sucked in
all the inhumans way back in like the
black swordsman arc yeah the sword can
get you even there if you want and this
is how skull knight helps guts out in
that instance but man we haven't seen
yet just how [ __ ] powerful this sword
can actually be
okay so this part is sort of a
transitional period between the scene we
just finished with the party and the
next big one we're greeted by yet more
stunningly and distressingly grotesque
artwork courtesy of miura himself
massive page spreads illustrating the
invasion of this land by the monsters
that emerged from the shadows crocodiles
tigers monsters and soldiers all the
same it's quite ominous and basically
our takeaway at this point should be
leaving this village will be no easy
task but fret not because roderick is a
badass who sets them up with a ship just
like that however before boarding the
ship they noticed that the harbour is
infested with monsters hundreds of them
shitake effectively tells guts to step
down and to leave it to her as they
stand guard they bide their time
together as shooter k becomes a raging
inferno monster leaving the surrounding
area as scorched earth destroying every
single enemy available to her i like
this not just for the cool visuals but
also the team effort it took to pull
this off it's nice however it's not
enough as tons more massive monsters
suddenly appear with guts going into
berserker mode and this magic man i
won't even attempt to embarrass myself
by trying to pronounce the name of
appears impressed by godzil's ability
and his armor and this is where things
get a little cool shitake reaches into
guts's psyche to create this conscious
state where guts gets to use the
berserker armor while fully in control
of his faculties thus creating a sort of
nice symbiotic relationship between
these two characters that were once sort
of at odds with each other moreover
specifically i love this mechanism
within the suit itself it has direct
ties to the cracks in the blade chapters
themes way back during the conviction
arc to use the suit to its fullest
potential is akin to embracing hatred
itself which if we look to the cracks in
the blade chapter we can see this is
akin to being selfish meaning the
hardest way the most courageous way is
to do what's best for those you love and
for those that depend on you that's what
makes for the correct moral choice in
this series and in essence is what i
love most about guts as a character this
internal struggle he's flawed has
desires endurance to do the right thing
even if it's the hardest path forward i
mean he's a true hero again this is a
terrific piece of development for
shirakei too since her introduction
she's been encouraged by one person or
another to have faith in those she
fights with in this case guts time and
again she recognizes the circumstances
guts finds himself in as impossible to
overcome and yet he still persists on
living on struggling forward this
fundamentally changes her and in this
scene we see just how much she has
changed willing to follow guts's rash
plan of action placing all of her faith
into him when he requests it it's a
wonderful team effort from both guts and
shitake that speaks to both their
characters perfectly shitake is required
to shoulder the mental toil while guts
absorbs the physical punishment this is
all to say that this fight was really
cool and honestly i was expecting it to
end here
however it
didn't and as it turns out this fight we
just concluded our discussion on was
actually just a warm-up fight to
something i never in a million years saw
coming
zod
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
zod makes the last second save and now
he's teaming up with guts i thought
about this one long and hard and a large
number of questions concerning this
occurrence stepped into my mind is zod
an entity that aligns himself with
individuals like guts and griffith when
they fight with full conviction against
a particular force does he have a camp
with which he chooses to fight with or
is it random and if it's not random what
dictates what his choices are
narratively there's this idea of destiny
in this story i've explored a number of
times and instead of retreading that
motivating factor for the millionth time
i'd like to look at what the story has
physically shown us thus far with
regards to him specifically that being
the number of times we've seen zyde prop
up therein and use that to derive some
sort of conclusion or at the very least
a theory we can firstly consider that
this foe he's facing off against with
guts is a shared enemy of both guts and
griffith so on the face of that alone it
doesn't seem contradictory to anything
we've seen from him recently ish one of
griffith's main critiques of most people
when asked about friendship was quite
cold and detached he has his dream he's
going to achieve it and he meant that in
the most honest and straightforward way
he could there are a few moments in the
story where griffith gets to speak
frankly and introspectively with us as
an audience to see so i see this
instance as pivotal not only for him but
how his relationship with guts will
ultimately conclude down the road you
just don't say stuff like this without
planning for it to service the
conclusion of an arc later on down the
line from this scene he cites that he
couldn't really have a friend beyond
someone that too chose to chase their
dream irrespective of who or what stood
in their way that then and only then
when another would pursue their dream in
full mind body and spirit could he
respect them enough to see them as an
equal worthy of friendship and bouncing
off of that idea presented by griffith
back during the golden age i wonder if
the fact griffith is so inhuman in his
devotion to his individual gold i wonder
if that is the mechanism by which he
seems to have an allyship or connection
with someone like zot and furthermore
why when guts falters he either faces
zod head on or receives help from his
metaphysical opposite in this world
skull knight there's a scene where zod
speaks to sonja for a short while within
which sonia acts as a proxy through
which a question can be posed towards
zod concerning his destiny it's a choice
he needs to make it is and i quote to
again battle a sword that cuts your own
flesh or to make it your own weapon
when i saw this quote i sort of leaned
back into my chair and tried to absorb
the meaning of this beyond the obvious
implications prophecy is clearly
something that plays a pivotal role in
this world and indeed this story when i
look at zod's contribution to the series
i think okay so he helps guts but then
he also doesn't he's sympathetic towards
guts but then he tries to kill him while
also helping his arch nemesis griffith
the quote directed towards zod in this
instance obviously speaks to a prime
directive he seems to be at odds with in
his mind and indeed with those around
him of similar nature as a monster he
like everyone else similar to him feels
this desire to squash guts and devour
him when he's weakest he is a marked
human after all however he chooses to
deny that much the same way ganeshka has
chosen his own path resulting in one of
the absolute best that i'm being best
two page spreads of not just the series
but any comic or any image i might have
ever seen i mean look at it i want this
as a poster never in all of my life have
i seen such incredible dynamic powerful
artwork in a manga but that too got me
thinking about what this means regarding
the second half of that quote from sonia
that being or to make the sword your own
weapon naturally this refers to guts in
this instance zod and gods in the heat
of battle chose to work alongside one
another to strike down ganeshka as
shared foe before going their separate
ways at the end with plenty of symbolic
gestures showing the growth guts has
undergone as a character for if he were
to have followed hatred he would have no
doubt died there and then which makes me
wonder if this quote can be extrapolated
upon and viewed through the lens of guts
and griffith's relationship specifically
there seemed to me at least to be a lot
of parallels between this quote zod and
guts's time spent on the pages of this
manga and so i wonder if a similar
choice might present itself forgot
somewhere down the line if we look all
the way back to the golden age following
his desertion of the band of the hawk he
left in search of his own dream in other
words he had no conviction at the time
which if we cast our minds back to the
chapter campfire of dreams is exactly
the topic of which he felt alienated by
and fast forward again once he lost
everything upon his return he gained a
tremendous hatred and by extension a
desired goal through the conviction arc
we then learned that this desire he had
to kill griffith was an entirely vapid
cowardly and selfish desire which flew
in the face of his true dream that being
to save kaska and in this moment it's
that exact impulse or dream which acts
as his salvation so it makes me wonder
griffith has been a sword which has
wounded guts in the past will guts like
zod had to do here and now
need to make that same decision a
decision he struggled with since the
start of the story will guts be forced
to make a decision not to kill griffith
but to instead fight alongside him for
some greater cause this seems like the
natural extreme or destination of this
philosophy the story has been exploring
and what makes sense to me right here
and now i think at this point it's
important to remember that we are only
seeing this story really through the
eyes and experiences of guts for the
most part the most introspection we get
from griffith comes by way of guts's
point of view mostly and the same could
be pretty much said for every other
character which is what makes scenes
like this one sonja shared with zod
prior to his save all the more
interesting and noteworthy we follow
guts's struggle and travels and due to
that it's easy to forget that with
regards to most other characters zod and
griffith included they each have
undergone a tremendous amount of
suffering and struggle in order to
achieve what their own respective goals
are guts denies himself the catharsis of
embracing hatred zog denies himself the
desire to devour our guts when he's most
vulnerable and perhaps even griffith the
most alien perspective to us right now
is also ignoring something he desires in
order to achieve his dream
switching gears for a second let's talk
a bit about griffith and his situation
the cushion advancement onto the
battlefield to face the weakened forces
of the holy see army was presented in
quite an unfamiliar fashion to me for
much of it there's virtually no dialogue
to speak of forcing our full attention
on the overwhelming strength of
ganeshka's forces things aren't looking
good but griffith and his new band of
the hawks show up in similar fashion as
they did in the golden age to save the
day i thought at the time of reading
this that he would no doubt be looking
to climb the ranks of this new army too
but griffith is 10 steps ahead
apparently he challenges ganishka to a
fight one-on-one at another location far
from here thus creating a scene wherein
he saves the entire army from certain
destruction this creates a fantastic
morale and rapport between himself and
his subjects to be right off the bat
couple that with the presence of
princess charlotte and this religious
figure and you have for yourself not
just a hero like we saw in golden age
but a full-blown savior in the eyes of
these people griffith has finally become
in many ways a god to these folks and
speaking of godlike farnese progresses
her training on the ship to the astral
plane with some of the most beautiful
page spreads i've seen from miura but
moreover this scene stands alongside one
of my favorite quotes in this arc
i guess even if you force back what was
lost it still won't be the way it was
in this short but brilliant quote
there's call backs to both cracks in the
blade and also casca's attempted suicide
in the golden age arc and funnily enough
it all stems from what guts perceives
koska to be to him at that very moment
in time there's no question that she's
an enormous burden the likes of which
even guts on his own would struggle to
handle and we are talking about someone
who can handle pretty much anything it
seems she's terrified of him she's
effectively an entirely different person
void of speech or really any form of
communication to him what's left he must
be thinking as she falls overboard and
guts jumps to save her unlike during the
golden age where he catches her she
slips through the fingers of his false
limb and falls before needing to be
rescued afterwards upon reflection gut
shares this profound quote that speaks
to the conflict in his mind concerning a
question that he was posed in a prior
section at the beach they are traveling
to pug's home in the hopes that casket
can be restored to her former self but
what if she doesn't want to change back
what if she can't what if you can't
force back what was lost what if it will
always be the way that it is now
no do-overs there's a tremendous amount
of sadness in this chapter and an all
too familiar sense of hopelessness to
boot the limb that once reached out and
saved casket from falling is now missing
replaced with a weapon a bringer of
death without the ability to save what's
most important to him anymore it's a
wonderful piece of symbolism that caps
off this section of the story with a
grim reminder that overcoming one's
demons isn't as simple as many stories
might lead you to believe this isn't a
disney film or a ghibli epic and despite
this being a tale of good and evil
fairies and dragons zombies and monsters
it's also a story detailing a realistic
struggle one man has to undergo for the
sake of others not just during a pivotal
part of his life wherein he learns a
single lesson to overcome a singular
trauma but instead this is a part of him
that he has now learned to live with and
manage for possibly the rest of his life
the beast that dwells within him is
there alive and well perhaps never to
truly leave him in peace of all the
demons that have followed god throughout
this long winding and harrowing journey
it's himself the beast in black
his darker tendencies that will force
him to run for the rest of his life
perhaps
further adding another layer of interest
and nuance to this growing quagmire of a
problem he's faced with
guts seems to find himself entrenched in
an unsolvable situation but at least for
the time being he still has his allies
his friends a surprisingly effective and
helpful newcomer to the party comes in
the form of rodrick with his incredible
nautical experience coming in
immeasurably handy to ensure their safe
passage across the sea it's a scene that
reinforces just how much guts needs
these people he surrounded himself with
thank heavens for them for without he
would almost certainly be lost in every
sense of the word but okay so that's
what's going on with guts's side of the
coin what about with griffith in prior
videos i reacted to and discussed
griffith's return to the physical world
exploring the massive changes his very
presence implies in isolation due to
this presence his being alive and well
once again it means both mortal and
astral worlds are getting closer and
many creatures and monsters that once
only existed in the first layer of the
astral plane are now invading the mortal
realm as i alluded to a moment ago this
is because griffith's newest incarnation
shouldn't exist and therefore breaks the
rules and laws of nature and the world
itself he's a super powerful astral
angel in a physical body with the likes
of scotland even going as far as to say
that the only way that they can stop him
is to also exist beneath the limbo that
defines the natural order of things make
sense of that if you can once
resurrected a new griffith formed this
new band of the falcon or band of the
hawk as it's referred to in this manga
that i'm reading composed of humans from
both midland and the cushing empire as
well as demons from the astral world and
so with this brand new army he begins
his offensive against the cushion
emperor ganeshka an incredibly powerful
apostle in his own right one that
negates the authority of the godhand and
wants to become a greater being too it's
pretty wild and man when these two guys
clash it gets even wilder in ways never
before committed to the pages of this
manga and i'm not just saying that these
chapters made such a huge impression on
me so much so that i would honestly make
it comparable to that of the eclipse
during the golden age i don't know if
that's a common opinion or not but it's
absolutely how i felt whilst reading it
because
this is it the culmination of griffith's
pursuit it feels like the beginning of
something entirely and profoundly new
prophetically this battle between
ganeshka and griffith ends up becoming
the fight that both literally and
figuratively sets the foundations for
griffith's rule on a figurative level
ganeshka presents such a profoundly
incomprehensible threat to not just
midland but the world at large so much
so that any individual that could
possibly topple this monster would no
doubt become a divine figure eligible to
rule the world in the eyes of those that
witnessed this struggle and i mean that
both in the eyes of man and monster
alike it's a total unification
poetically and physically this is the
ultimate vision of the kingdom griffith
hat this battle not only is iconic for
protecting the world but also as the
first instance for both humans and
demons collaborating and helping each
other in this effort this is the
eradication of war and the birth of a
new era the transformation kanishka
undergoes is unlike any i've seen in any
manga it's horrifying while also
managing to make me feel exceptionally
insignificant and small as a reader the
sense of scale miura manages to capture
in these drawings is not only beautiful
in a horrific sense but also vital for
this battle's final moments to work
effectively the greater the threat
gnishka can convince us he's capable of
the more incredible the people of
midland and by extension we as an
audience feel griffith's conquest will
be furthermore the battle literally sets
the foundations for griffith's rule by
physically acting as the catalyst that
drags the worlds of the astral and
mortal realms together in a convincing
fashion creating a kingdom the likes of
which only exist in the minds of
griffith and children's storybooks the
result is something so incredibly
outlandish and ethereal yet oddly
fitting for a series that has dealt with
so much grotesque realism this is a
gorgeous moment of fantasy and respite a
culmination of everything griffith has
ever wanted it seems and the most
impressive thing is it's all conveyed
with no dialogue this is like attempting
a world record and being so confident in
your abilities to succeed in that effort
that you do it blindfolded this singular
choice set this battle apart from every
other clash in the series on a
fundamental level for me it felt as
though i was watching one of those
intense epic battles on film like lord
of the rings that helms deep with
kanishka's terror and fear of losing to
griffith with his fear of the invasion
he sees with his fear of the feelings
griffith's presence forces him to feel
it leads him to make the strategic and
rash decisions that on the surface made
for a tremendously imposing adversary
all the while unconsciously playing
right into the hands of prophecy
unwittingly and with ganishka being one
of the few demonic figures that actually
pushes against face failing it makes me
wonder how much control if any guts and
his party of friends possesses in
reality skull knight effectively told
godz that he has to defy destiny but
perhaps his efforts to defy destiny are
actually part of a greater plan and
that's what makes this such an
incredible story you have no idea which
way it's going to go
which brings us to our final stop on
this long journey it's time to tackle
the unfinished
fantasia arc
the boat adventures i feel like those
that read this release to release might
have had a very different experience to
share than what i did with this now
infamous section but we'll get to that
after a very dense conclusion courtesy
of the previous arc what with griffith's
final battle with ganeshka the merging
of the both physical and astral worlds
and the resurgence of the city of
falconia this next boat section is in a
similar way to the lost children's act
of conviction quite short and simple you
know minus the mountain of smoldering
child corpses for the most part it's
presented as a classic heisu's adventure
would our heroes need to navigate while
being attacked by incredibly dangerous
sea creatures and monsters while there
we get to interact with brand new
characters like isma who i love and even
more fantastical creatures on the side
of light
why do i get the feeling sanji would
love it here right now but all of this
in hindsight is minor to me for unlike
lost children which felt like a much
needed breather after the eclipse within
this adventure story we get to re-engage
with long-running mysteries from the
previous stories like one moon knight
boy who i feel at this point must be
that weird monster fetus creature casca
was drawn to following the eclipse in
the golden age act which means this
could be the child of both griffith and
casca perhaps which runs the risk of
being one of the most [ __ ] up things
this series has done which is a tall
order but that is neither here nor there
and i hope for the love of god that i'm
wrong in addition to that we also get a
giant monster as the final boss to allow
guts to do what he does best however one
of the only things i knew about this
section before i started reading it was
that it was largely hated online i
suspect mostly because it lasted for
years of publications during which the
berserk series fell into a long hiatus
in addition to muir at the time
releasing about two chapters a year to
advance the story however personally
reading it all in one go within about an
hour which i'm sure sounds insane to you
that waited over six years to finish
this part of the story i found that i
breezed through this little conflict
with one of the most goofy villain type
concepts we've yet seen committed to the
series however speaking more precisely
about the story at hand the highlights
of the story for me have to be fairness
continuing up her journey into becoming
a powerful magic wielder focused on the
defense of her family unit and of course
shooter k's activity as it connects two
gutses once again one of the longest
running tales in this long and winding
story is that of how gutz tends to fight
and that's alone from a young age he's
always been alone and when he allows
himself the chance to connect to other
people the most horrific events befall
them all however simultaneously as the
world itself grows longer in the tooth
so too do the dangers and
responsibilities he's forced to contend
with in many ways this is a metaphor for
life and in this particular instance now
armed with the berserker armor guts is
forced to rely on his allies and friends
more than he ever has in the past he no
longer can just fight and slay creatures
at will as time passes on by his goal of
protecting kaska and his friends becomes
more than he can handle without the
berserker armor which itself comes with
its own terrible toll in his body thus
creating a necessity for cedar k's
involvement and eventually unexpectedly
surprising aid of the moonlight boy
spring flower of days long past spring
flower of days long ago is a
surprisingly short series of chapters
that i feel punch way above their weight
in terms of emotional resonance and
symbolism narratively a surface level
reading of the events that take place
would tell you that this section serves
to inform the readers of guts's first
ever experience with elves through a
flashback namely chitch in this instance
is the elf going one level deeper
there's a consistency being employed
here too we've been told that elves are
drawn to honest wounded humans and so
when we see this little creature look to
help guts in his dying moments this
sequence fits that billing however all
of that aside what i love about this
section isn't any of that really instead
it's how beautiful this sequence is both
visually and metaphorically managing to
find the beauty in the most dreary of
places all the while reinforcing to us
who gotz is as a character a moment that
tugs on these strings simultaneously has
to be that of this scene during his
lowest moment he notices a flower
managing to bloom in his freezing cold
cell and alongside it he sees with his
very own two eyes a little elf perhaps
he can see it because he's destined to
be the person he eventually becomes or
perhaps he sees chitch because he's just
a kid a kid that's forced to be more
mature and grown up in order to survive
however with that said the important
part of this little flashback isn't to
highlight how gutz tries to be more
adult-like but instead highlights what
makes him distinct from everyone else
chitch has come across during her time
in this cell and what makes him
different isn't his sword his safety
blanket but a concern he has for
another's life and at great cost to his
own despite what circumstances betrayed
his trust and innocence earlier in the
story in other words this short story
proves to us that guts is foundationally
a kind person that would go out of his
way to save any life no matter the cost
to his own which is a far cry from the
monster so many think of him as today
the city of falconia
this place is huge and for the first
time in the series rickard takes the
leading role as a point of view
character rickett had already been
established as an important character
way way before these events and in both
interesting and unfortunate fashion this
is how his story truly begins to unfold
predominantly what this section offers
is an exploration into falconia and the
picture of griffith's ambition even with
his dream having come true in this
paradise we can see some cracks already
starting to form through rickard's
choices roxas not being 100 loyal to the
throne and a host of secondary threads
that come as a result of a certain
butterfly effect falconia may be a
utopia however its very existence means
that nowhere else can be peaceful and
safe true to griffith's character it's
either his way or the highway and
there's also this top tier moment where
rickard finally goes from human to
apostle by releasing his true form a man
with two gigantic balls as he will
smith's griffith in a phenomenal
two-page spread spitting straight facts
towards the single most powerful entity
in this world
griffith this moment took me completely
by surprise and in that very instance
rickard who had already been a brilliant
character in my eyes became one of the
most brave in the series
[ __ ]
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
oh my god
i was not expecting that
oh my god
yes rickard yes
oh that that was so good absolute alpha
move
sadly there are a host of different
characters and plot points established
in this section that will probably never
see a proper resolution and for that
reason i'll just move on to the final
section of the story and it's my
favorite part the corridor of dreams
this section of the story shows quintara
miura and i believe berserk at their
respective peaks there has never been a
single piece of fiction that has
affected me quite as much as this has
the profound sense of despair pain
sadness hope and love i felt during my
time reading this cannot be compared to
anything i've either seen or read in the
past
it surpasses quite literally everything
as the previous arc saw the culmination
of griffith's dream so too does the
landing on the shores of scale lake
indicate the end of the journey for guts
and the black swordsman party finally
they have arrived at the kingdom of
elfhem where they meet the inhabitants
of the elf kingdom elves witches and
other such magical and fantastical
creatures it's clear that this is the
perfect land to develop both shooter k
and farnese and oh boy do they develop
but above anything and everything else
that this story has dealt with since the
golden age arc i've longed for the
answer to one question can casca be
saved has the journey been worth it can
they bring kaska back this section which
drives into the subject matter of
kaska's retrieval from her subconscious
begins in chapter 347 entitled the
flower storm monarch within which once
again magic is used to emphasize and
facilitate a narrative direction and
right now i'd like to use this as an
opportunity to discuss what i love about
magic in storytelling and indeed berserk
specifically there's a wonderful video
called how to write great magic by a
brilliant creator on this platform
called the closer look i highly
recommend you check out his work and
that video because in it it points to
the importance of what we value as
people the aspects of great stories that
have stood the test of time that stay in
our minds this difference he
hypothesizes is the root cause for why
we remember old stories like that of
king midas not for his name but for the
power to turn everything he touches to
gold the lesson or message it wants to
communicate and due to that more of us
likely remember the magic of that story
and its subsequent meaning and less of
us will remember the name of that story
and i think that's the reason the most
iconic section of the story to this day
remains to be the eclipse among the
fanbase and why this magical encounter
will be remembered as my favorite moment
in the series and perhaps all of fiction
partially for how well the magic at hand
served the story's overarching message
but also due to how profoundly this
story resonated with me personally i'd
consider myself a relatively
well-adjusted guy i have a large circle
of truly wonderful friends i have an
amazing partner and my relationship with
my family is solid but something i have
always struggled with is trust i do not
trust easily and for the majority of my
relationships i found that i truly do
not trust those altruistically i have
interpersonal relationships with to this
day i think the amount of people i truly
trust can be counted on a single hand
and even then i think i may have a digit
or two to spare and i say that because i
feel like the moment that connected with
me first in this section wasn't just the
incredible journey that follows but
instead got his reaction when he heard
he couldn't go personally to try and
bring casca back himself ever since
reaching this land of elephant he's
consistently pushed to get kaska to the
correct location and into the right
hands to begin this process guts is a
man of action and for him
that's his love language he's not able
to really communicate his feelings in
any other way and so he chooses to do
things by action and so when he was told
he couldn't go and the farnese and
shirakei had to do it in instead the
conflicted expression that descended
across his face was enough to send
shivers down my spine i felt like that
was me and boyd did me or nail it i've
spoken about this plenty of times in
this video the slow progression of guts
from telling himself comforting
self-centered lies to someone that has
to learn to share the load the burden
the struggle with this effectively being
his most difficult task thus far to do
nothing but wait to allow someone else
to carry out what is most important to
him and that is the ultimate trust
exercise and much like guts
this would shatter me
and shatter me this absolutely did in
more ways than one the dreamlike
sequence that they have to find their
way through is one of the most haunting
experiences i've had while reading the
moment of realization i had when i saw
that injured hound dragging the casket
was enough to reduce me to a sobbing
mess the imagery contained in this
section is some of the most difficult
for me to journey through i have so many
emotional connections to these
characters and to see their pain laid
bare like this through soul destroyingly
beautiful imagery is more than enough to
place these chapters as the very best or
most effective in the series for me to
bring casca back shitake and farnese
have to find the many missing pieces of
the broken doll that is kaska's identity
with the journey that they all
collectively go on acting as a means of
experiencing everything she's felt up
until that point and perhaps most
importantly how she views guts and of
course
within the fragmented memories of her
own unconscious interpretations of guts
it's a beautiful way to finally
understand her true feelings something
that was kept as a mystery for such a
long time guts is not precisely seen as
a white knight but as this giant black
hound forever there as the watchful
protector wounded and almost helplessly
hobbling forward in the hopes that he
still might be able to save the only
person in the world that he truly loves
contrasted with this you'll find her
memories of him prior to the eclipse
held in an almost divine regard the
portrayal of their more intimate moments
shared like campfire dreams another one
of my favorite chapters are depicted
with astonishing beauty griffith's
portrayal on the other hand is entirely
different yes he is seen as the falcon
of light to the entire world but here in
casca's dreams we see the representation
of his true nature through the eyes of
kaska herself a giant black specter
ready to capture and tear down to pieces
everything that stands before him and
its guts her protector and loyal
companion the one that is always there
for her that stands up to that imposing
adversary it's incredible to tie this
whole story and kaska's retrieval
together in a fashion that truly feels
like an end of a long journey it's
farnese who's the one that puts the
final fragment into casca's broken soul
after experiencing everything kaska has
felt to this point sharing her happy and
sad moments her joys and fears in the
most literal of ways its fairness the
one that shared a similar parallel story
to casca is the one who brings her back
from the abyss which leads into one of
the most beautiful show don't tell
panels in the entire manga
foreign
[Music]
talking to each other in many ways for
the very first time farnese asks if she
remembers guts and with the mere
pronunciation of his name without even
finishing the sentence
we turn the page and we see casca's
reaction an entire story between these
two characters a storm of feelings
questions and memories
everything portrayed in one single
teary-eyed expressive panel this if
nothing else makes berserk worth it in
my book a mission achieved by the people
he needed to trust that could only have
been accomplished and completed by those
very individuals unfortunately however
moments later when they moved to reunite
with each other the same visual
technique is employed to equally
catastrophic effect when casca is
finally reunited with guts she doesn't
see him she sees something entirely
different
[Music]
the man she once knew has been scared by
this struggle quite literally he has
struggled to hold himself together he's
no longer the man she remembers and
what's more evokes memories from the
darkest traumas of her life the monster
guts had to be calm in order to survive
in order to protect and create this
reality for casca is the very aspect of
him that terrifies and panics her just
like the story of king midas guts no
longer can have what's most important to
him in this world
the ending and final thoughts at this
moment in time both guts and griffith
are similar in that they are following
their own convictions despite their safe
and comfortable circumstances griffith
wants to seize more control over more
land by enacting his will unto those
that seek his help and guts is faced
with a choice a choice which no doubt
would have been answered had the series
continued in his current trajectory i
feel in the most simplistic of ways
berserk is not only the story of guts
but more broadly the story of making the
right choices for the right reasons
within the golden age during campfire of
dreams guts reconciles that he might not
ever feel a true connection with anyone
and on the back of that sentiment he
decides to embark on a journey of
self-discovery to find his own dream his
own conviction which ultimately leads
him to nothing but isolation an
isolation that eventually brings him
back to casca similarly griffith during
that early portion chooses to take
chance after chance to protect guts
despite it coming at a cost to his dream
which led him to a certain snowy
mountaintop the likes of which led to
the single most horrific event in the
entire story an event that threw guts
into a whirlwind rage the likes of which
he hasn't completely surfaced from even
after one of my favorite chapters in the
entire series cracks in the blade a
chapter that outlines the dangers of
this indulgent and selfish quest for
revenge guts is determined to see
through to the bitter end despite what
he stands to lose in the process but gut
says no to this impulse he says no to
rage resentment revenge and every other
aspect of his personal scars griffith
has left him with because he chooses her
he accepts her as worth it there's a
brief moment in the middle of that
intimate chapter between guts and casca
in the golden age that i find
fascinating a moment that kaska is left
to make her own decision in a turn of
events that we have not seen much of
since then gutz is entirely vulnerable
with all of his physical and
psychological scars laid to bear for her
to see plain as day she sees a dangerous
wounded creature that's been abused
their entire life one that can't bring
himself to trust anyone and yet in this
moment she accepts him for who he is she
loves him for who he is and wants to be
there for him because of who he is scars
and all and in a similar way i think
guts following this moment in chapter
364 will have to make a similar choice
one that hackens back to not only the
cracks in the blade but indeed that
treasured meeting with kaska it's no
coincidence that guts got to see skull
knight's memories while wearing his suit
of armor it's clearly symbolic not only
have got seen through the eyes of his
confidant but indeed walking in his
boots walking his path through these
visions we see a skull night that
followed a path of destruction and
revenge one that led him to lose what
was most important to him a revenge that
to this day still consumes him entirely
this story however is not one that
hinges on the decisions of just one
individual in the same way the moon
cannot create an eclipse without the sun
guts's journey of self-discovery cannot
exist without griffin neither can exist
without the other one of the final
revelations in the story is that of the
moonlight boy's true identity that is a
substantial part of griffith's being in
the mortal world countless times during
the golden age griffith is said to be
childlike and innocent both in
appearance and the aura he exudes this
too is confirmed by the moonlight boy
during the last few chapters apart from
a few obvious and more grotesque
implications that this might imply i
genuinely believe that this is a visual
representation or manifestation for the
conflict in perfect's mind the same
conflict which prevented him from taking
the optimal path towards his dreams
early on in the golden age one that took
chances to protect guts at all costs
much like those that we saw on the beach
and the pirate sections of this very
story too the final revelation by miura
while i can see why it upsets some
people for leaving us on the largest
cliffhanger in the series i will also
say that i think it's an incredible
moment for the series to end with
boasting the look of kaska and guts's
dark features under the full moon's
light and the soft and fair features of
griffith beneath the sun this instance
is a physical manifestation of the very
moment that has defined this entire
series the eclipse a coming together of
both light and dark to create something
entirely new and so now can taramira and
the team behind this breathtaking story
ask us the audience one final question
what path does the man who we know is
naturally kind but filled with a
nurtured rage follow what path does the
man who's naturally rageful but nurtured
to be kind follow can guts accept that
what's done is done and live out the
rest of his life in peace as the dutiful
protector and companion to casca or does
he embrace the rageful hound that lurks
right beneath the surface can griffith
live out his dream while ignoring what's
undeniably important to him in the
process guts
in the end berserk asks us to ask
ourselves
who are we really and is lying to
ourselves worth it or a comfortable
fantasy
kintara miura was fired for being too
good that's a common line you hear from
anyone who talks about him and his work
and honestly it takes an honest author
and former employer like george morikawa
the creator of hajime no ipo to admit
something like that what would have
happened if miura kept working as an
assistant and never came out as a solo
artist reading interviews from different
colleagues and friends who knew him it's
clear how much he influenced everyone
around him in a positive way and how big
the mark he left as a mangaka truly is
now if you got to this point in the
video there's likely no need to explain
to you why or to stress how important
berserk truly is not only to the world
of manga but to media and storytelling
in general just how much would be lost
to us if miura never met someone that
encouraged him to not work as an
assistant and to just go for it what
would have happened if he never tried
and ever became the obsessive perfection
seeking author he would later become
known as around the world osamu tetsuka
or as some might remember him as the
godfather of manga was constantly asked
questions like why do you work like this
why would anyone do something like this
to themselves why do you do what you do
if you know how crazy it is and to that
he would lose himself for a second
staring vacantly at something only he
could understand breaking only to
respond with a smiling
i wonder why how passionate an artist is
is something only they can understand
and maybe there are no real motives to
do what they do maybe they just do it
because that's the only way they know
how to live he died doing what he wanted
no matter what right i'd bet he died
happy kintara miura chose to dedicate
his entire life to his work and even
with the help of studio gaga the team he
would later allow to help him with the
serialization of berserk he would become
more and more obsessive with putting out
his best efforts into his manga this
work was his life and even if he'll
never know how positively berserk's
impact has affected people around the
world i hope he felt proud about what he
achieved
proud of the first step he took in the
80s when he was first fired and became a
solo author a perfectionist will never
be satisfied but i hope that he never
finished drawing a single page or panel
with any sense of regret simply because
he gave it it's all
rest in peace and thank you kentaro
miura
[Music]
foreign foreign
hoodoo
[Music]